before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos guys
while you're at it we just dropped
membership so if you want to be a part
of the live chat the second half of the
show sign up for our memberships we all
also have exclusive behind the scenes
content so today we have a lovely panel
shout out to you guys
so why don't we go around everyone say
your name your age your relationship
status and where you're from starting
with you
hello everyone watching at home my name
is jordan i'm 28 years old from
southeast london and i am in a
relationship of three years
i'm daley i'm from luton and essex i'm
26 and i'm one half of the domino effect
podcast and i'm taken
[Laughter]
i'm elisa i'm 27
and i'm from east london
and i'm taking
i'm rhianne i'm from um i'm 29 i'm from
west london in north west london
um
my name is sehail i'm 29 and i'm from
north london and my relationship status
is out of space
i'm daniel i'm 29 from southeast london
and i'm just chilling
[Laughter]
so what does that mean i don't get it
single butt chilling you're single but
challenge single watch okay okay
so
so today's topic
we have a baby mama that thinks
her baby daddy she it's her fourth kid
with the baby daddy and that he should
pay for the kids that aren't his so ish
will you pull up the video that set the
internet ablaze of this lovely
lovely woman
but basically
she um has four kids and the fourth baby
daddy brought over his kid mcdonald's
and essentially she feels that like he
should bring mcdonald's for all of the
children not just his
so ish is going to play the video in one
second
yeah it's that one
look there you go and i bet you he only
got one thing in there
i bet you he don't even
i'm finna expose a lot of him so people
can see how he really is it ain't more
than it ain't more than enough food in
that bag for everybody
what's up
because i'm going to expose you
because they don't look they don't look
enough for all my kids
they don't look enough for all my kids
what is that that's just one burger one
burger one fries that's what he like
what do you mean okay what about my
other kids
okay but then your kids siblings though
what are you talking about you might
kiss them your kids siblings though
if you're trying to help out though
you're not helping out my son like how
are you helping yourself where you're
only getting careful for just him and
not the other kids his siblings
are his siblings though
he's not going to eat in front of all
his other siblings and they're not
eating mcdonald's
why do i gotta
no no no he's not going to eat that oil
if you can't bring enough for everybody
so you're telling me that i gotta break
so when i buy my bring myself food i got
to bring your kids food to them yes
how is that dumb you sound
okay but if you're gonna bring one you
need to bring it for all
how do they look that i'm playing one
child eat mcdonald's and all the rest of
the kids can't eat no [ __ ] mcdonald's
you know i get food stamps on that left
three kids
three kids
yeah
they're his siblings you know what you
was getting into when you had a baby
okay but you still had a baby with me
who have kids with other people i still
have other kids
because i'm exposed everybody think
you're such a muffin good daddy
no you're not no you're not you're
foolish in this [ __ ] you only come here
with one
piece of food for one child the child
that's mine silly
no that's dumb that you can't feed the
other kids don't feed nobody at all then
he can't take that
he can't eat it maybe if you had one or
two [ __ ] like you know maybe you got
four is three extra kids what the well
like going to mama account spend money
on those all those kids this time
they're about my kids them are your kids
siblings though
those are your [ __ ] kids siblings
yeah
so don't no i didn't say you have to
take care of them you can bring them
something to eat if you bring one
something to eat i bring food every
other day what do you mean exactly but
you don't ever bring food for the other
ones you know i get my food stamps
okay but i'm saying
we share the same kids as well
absolutely
no no you know what fine give it here
thank you give here give me here
give it here
doug
he ain't eating this
you
you just do that because you ain't
bringing up for all the other
you stupid stupid
selfish is a like you're dumb as hell
you're dumb as hell he's not going to
eat that
yup
anyway dumb he's not going to do it if
you can't do it for all don't do it for
none of them
child something
so then this is part two this is her
response video
me right now because
i'm the baby model who was upset at her
baby daddy because he only decided to
give his child
mcdonald's and not the rest of my other
three kids i have four kids
you know the situation
when you dated me
our child is the youngest child
so keep that in mind before y'all make
me the villain that means all my other
kids knew him he was buying the
mcdonald's when we were together
my kids have to go through a transition
of our breakup as well like yeah me and
you broke up but my kids got to feel it
too so now
my kids have to see only one of their
siblings get mcdonald's and not the rest
of them and they know it's coming from
you because of course like me and you
used to be together they used to see you
you used to do it for them but now you
don't want to do that for them anymore
like to me that's petty
that's petty like it's not fair like
you're not going to give
one child mcdonald's and not all the
other kids mcdonald's like i'm not going
and then on top of that you mean to tell
me you can dip and dab and want to do it
sometimes but yet you can't see all my
other kids mcdonald's though
that's what you mean to tell me like i'm
not going for that i'ma stand on what i
said and i don't care what everybody
else have to say about it y'all could
judge me oh well i could be the villain
but i said what i said like if you can't
bring everybody mcdonald's then can't
nobody have mcdonald's then
perry
okay
we're back-ish yeah okay
so
um you guys saw the video
what are your initial thoughts
well first things first let's get
let's get the real issue out of the way
why are you feeding your child
mcdonald's
get some proper food for your child
that's my so that's my that's my beef no
pun intended
[Laughter]
and secondly
to the woman i think the man is under
absolutely no obligation to cater to the
other kids regardless of whether he
knows them or not regardless of whether
them kids were there when you were with
him it doesn't matter at the end of the
day that's his child he has no moral
obligation
to
to fend for the other kids that's his
one child
i don't i don't really feel like there's
any criticism that he needs
to come his way for taking care of just
his child
that's my personal opinion on the matter
okay what do you guys think
i agree um but i think i have two
talking to the mic a little closer i
agree but like i think
he doesn't have to do it but it would
have been a nice just gesture i agree
she didn't need to go off on him like
that like she went nuts as if all them
kids are his wife did not so i think
that she could have gone about it a
different way um but
yeah he doesn't have to do if you're
really looking at it but he could have
done it just to be nice and not have the
other kids feel left out but his pocket
he might not have it even though i know
it's mcdonald's
but he might have had it we don't know
what his pockets are saying so that's my
thoughts on it
i think whenever together like if you're
with someone and she's she's glogging
your meat it's makes sense that you'd
look after your kids
but once you stop feeding your meat
those kids are not getting fed no more
like yeah
well said um
it is it is a matter of perspective
isn't it because i feel like just like
what they just said um
i think if you are with a person
then
if you've been brought into the
relationship and there are children
like you can't it's kind of your
responsibility to be you know
i guess not not technically a step dad
but to look out for the children as well
because they are children but then if
you're not together anymore then that's
a little bit different
but i will also say if you're going to
bring
a child something and there's other
children around whether they're your
kids or not yeah exactly you know
there's going to be kids around so i
feel like there has to be equal share of
just whatever you bring
or just don't bring it at all
um i agree and also the context of
you know how long were they together
because she did say it was her boyfriend
and
i assume from what she said the youngest
child is his so
she knew well he knew that she had three
children
and
as a man it's like
you're
providing for one child that is yours
because it's yours not because it's the
right thing to do but you're just doing
it because it's your child
if you're gonna do it you know have a
bit of integrity if you can't afford it
at least get two big macs or something
you know what i mean so there's
something to split up between the kids
and not
allow the other children to feel left
out you know because some people they'll
grow up with kind of animosity towards
each other as siblings knowing that
their sibling got this and they got
nothing but shouldn't she have thought
of that before sleeping with all these
different baby daddies
yeah because why is that his problem he
didn't make he didn't have a bunch of
different baby mamas what if what if it
was vice versa right is she required to
give money if she's dating a guy with
multiple different kids but is she
supposed to give money to all the or
give food to every kid
depends if they're living together
if if the kids are living with him no
but no when they're not together it's
disputed because it's the other way
around as a woman so if you're in a
relationship with someone and you know
they have children and you break up and
you were doing certain things and the
children kind of were used to that you
could be like yeah i will do that
but but for how long
well they got that so their dad should
be providing for as well do you know
what i mean so if your dad is filling in
his slot you won't really feel that kind
of way but as the as the as it pertains
to the mother like
yeah she needs to stop in my opinion if
you've got four kids we don't know how
many two like how many dads are involved
but she was too many yeah yeah no no
she's spreading it finn like she's
really she's really getting burst i
think two dads is like more than
more than enough yeah
i just wanted to add um
i
think in the context of how she was
speaking about the situation i think she
was right and the reason why is because
if you as a step as a dad
bring a child food for them to eat in
front of their siblings
it creates a dynamic where
their siblings will
start to have hatred or resentment for
that kid what the dad should have done
is if he wants to bring the kid
mcdonald's the kids got to go with the
dad
away from the other siblings but he
offered in the video to take their son
into the car
but that's not
i'm talking about for the day you've got
to take him away from the situation
like so why does he have to pay for her
poor decisions but then he he made a
poor decision as well that's true
but but but he didn't make the poor
decision of having multiple different
baby mama or baby daddy he made the
point so why doesn't why doesn't the
baby that's on the other baby daddies
yeah but he doesn't have to bring her
mcdonald's at all but he still slept
with her knowing she had three children
with multiple men can i just ask what
was wrong with the mum i'm assuming all
of the kids
live with the mum yes so what was wrong
with the mom saying don't bring the kid
mcdonald's how about i just make them
awesome food
i don't know do you know what i think
it's speaking to them sorry i think it
was her delivery because there's there's
a completely different way that you
could have wedded that which would have
made that whole situation completely
different but
i feel like the way she wedded it
made her sound entitled and it's not
yeah you're right it's not his kids but
it would have been nicer for him to
bring food for everyone but at the end
of the day it's still not his response
yeah at the end of that i think there's
there's a fine line between integra
somebody in there mentioned integrity
and i do i do agree really but
i think what needs to be understood
ultimately is that there's no obligation
for him to do so might he look like a
prick if he doesn't that's fine that's
everybody's entitled to the opinion but
i don't think he's still under any
obligation if he chooses not to i don't
think anybody can really come at him
because he's yeah that's his child he
doesn't have any obligation to take it
like i don't know she shouldn't be able
to say [ __ ]
other than thank you yeah honestly he's
doing it on camera so yeah that adds to
it that doesn't matter and on top of
that did you notice she has fake nails
fake lashes and a weave well you can't
afford mcdonald's for your kids i don't
even get fake nails because they're
expensive
that's like a couple what like a hundred
bucks every two i'm cheap
and so you can afford that but you can't
afford to give your kids mcdonald's
doesn't that say that she's kind of
selfish
let's just let's look ultimately at the
fact that she's got four kids
so let's say she's with one of the dads
that's three men she's no longer with
i think we could all agree she's the one
who's [ __ ] up entirely yeah like if
she's cool a spider spider if she wants
if she wanted to work it out if she
wants the mcdonald's work it out with
him figure out how to get along with a
man yeah because she did say her food
stamps won't come until a week or
something okay well then get a job
get a job
food stamps but fake nails that's the
thing she knows that she knows how to
ration food and resources but she
doesn't know how to ration her [ __ ]
lies
i do feel like we're missing the point a
little bit though um i think
for me everything everyone's saying is
like perfectly fair but i feel like
if we look at christmas for example
and you're going into anyone's house
you're going with presents and there's
children
in the house you're going to take a gift
for all the children in the house you're
not going to say i'm bringing a gift
for one child yeah but not all men can
afford that yeah for one and that's fine
and that's fine so if you can't there's
a different way to do it you won't do it
in front of the rest of the children
mm-hmm like someone said you can get a
bucket that they can all share
you can if you can afford
kids
if you if you can afford a meal at
mcdonald's let's just say now these days
mcdonald's is about seven pounds
you can go somewhere else
and get literally chicken and chips
that can feed a whole lot for seven but
why is that on here
why is that on him it's not if i don't
feel like it's on him particularly but i
feel like you need to think about these
things especially when there's children
involved yeah it's so much
much more deeper than when the children
involved it's great it's greater than
him and the woman of course not but he
but he offered to take the kid in the
car
he's still so conscious decision to say
i'm just getting my child food and
turning up with much
as he should because that money adds up
three three mouths to feed even if he
does it once a week that adds up over
time
has a deep pocket like even when you
look at the bag the bag looks like it's
struggling yeah you know what i don't
know if you got that one fresh so the
fact that then again he didn't look too
built so he looked like he's drunk yeah
can i just add but if they were together
and they weren't broken up he would be
providing for those three children other
children as well as he was it would not
have been he wouldn't have been up for
discussion but she did say but men are
motivated by [ __ ] so the fact that
you're not free
of course he's not going he's not going
to pay for those kids very it's very
simple a man will provide resources once
they have that i know people like to
talk about love and respect is very
transactional are you related
this is a mating strategy for women she
wants she wants to extract the resources
with nothing in return you just want to
exist this is a different level and then
and then it just pisses me off because i
don't even get fake nails
go get a job
like i don't understand why these girls
can't just work
because she got four kids and she might
be pregnant again okay then do 50 50
custody with the dads
there's ways around it but i think she
shot herself in the foot by speaking and
filming in the way that she did she put
clout before outcomes
out before communication she put clout
before integrity she put clout before
being a mature adult that you're a
parent your children could grow up and
see this on the internet tick tock all
these years i think they should take i
think he should have full custody after
that video
that's right that's a bit extreme i
can't imagine that's a bit extreme
because she's clearly not stable the
reason why i agree with that sorry
she's clearly not stable you can't be
mentally stable if you think it's cool
to put the father of your kid on the
internet like there's something wrong
with you no i think well
i think i think
her thing is selfish i think that she
wasn't even thinking about her kids per
se it was about embarrassing him as
we've discussed before
a lot of women when they break up with a
man they still want to control his life
be emotionally mentally
if they can't physically control it with
the you know but
i think it's important that
we can't just say oh she's she's
unstable i think she's irresponsible
when she needs to go maybe go to
parenting classes counseling something
to level off mm-hmm
she covered his face
wow did she did she did she was saying
was she what was that was that the video
you couldn't see his face it was blurred
out oh so she had something did she
comfortable
oh no
okay but everyone that knows her knows
who her baby daddy is so everyone in the
town
everyone in the town is going to know
who that is
yeah yeah
and like men free and genuinely if you
have like i'm thinking of my mom my mom
would never do that like who are these
women it's for clout because it
generates attention she'll probably get
her new man via the internet you know oh
babes you look cute you were saying this
like oh i get mail attention dms now and
all that you know but the reason why i
do agree with pearl is because
that decision she made
the bigger picture
if you
for her for her to film the man turning
up and trying to embarrass him knowing
that the world's going to see that and
everybody who knows them as a couple
knows all the kids let's face it if
she's had four men she's likely slept
with loads more around town they all
know who they are for her to make that
decision
it says something on a deeper level
she's not
she's not mentally stable enough to make
the right decisions that's personally
what i believe so for that i think
there's absolutely a good case to be
made that she's probably not well enough
to look after the kids solely you should
have some involvement i disagree
with emotionally guys one at a time one
at a time i just i just feel like it's a
little bit deeper than the woman not
being like emotionally stable i think
for like 110
she's very untitled 110 she's acting out
and she wants clout that's the new age
we know all that but i do feel like it
can be deeper than that moment in itself
it could have been something that's
going on ongoing with the man yeah we
don't know that obviously we can only
see a little picture
right right yeah but part of the group
part of being an adult is thinking hmm
maybe i shouldn't put this on the
internet
and so to me if you are like mentally if
you're doing that that says you were
mentally still a child yeah so very
immature you are not old enough to have
children yeah so if that was me i would
say give the custody to the father
because he was the only one acting
normal and providing for them
is the context of the situation we do
not know so in that instance in that
perspective
we could say she was i i would say she
was emotionally charged she was running
on adrenaline of he may be doing that
one or two times maybe more and it's
easy for us to say yeah give custody to
the dad we don't know what that does
okay let's let's flip this script what
if it was a dude doing this what if it
was a dude holding it again a phone at a
woman yeah doing the same thing straight
to cool
it's totally it would be deemed totally
different because men respond different
to situations because women are given
the benefit of the doubt in men are no
no
are men are men
is it different for men or society's
views on the situation different
families not different for men because
they they respond differently so men are
not outwardly um
they wouldn't necessarily show you
certain things outwardly they would hold
it inside yeah that's fine but
but you can you not believe that society
would would come down on the man more so
in that situation
so what is it i i've been emotionally
charged and not thrown at you yeah i
think that's a cop out i think
emotionally charged i think yeah that's
how that's how people respond though it
doesn't make it right emotion
that's how that's how mentally unstable
people respond mentally stable people
don't respond like that mentally
unstable people respond like that every
single time
yeah
every single time more often
one at a time
also if i punch someone
and then i say i was an emotion i was
emotionally charged does that make it
excusable
so where's the butts
it doesn't make it
well if you're in your period and you
punch a man you'll probably get away
with it though
that's true
and there'll be a bot because i was
emotionally charged yeah about
emotionally charged it's about i just
wanna show you yeah no there's both
there's no one there's no there's no
contacts it's about there's no excuse
i'm like i just think we always make
excuses for women i don't care if she
was emotionally charged you are acting
like a child you are putting yourself
before your kids by putting this on the
internet
you are you are also wasting the food
that was for your child like you you
don't want the debate of that with the
debate to that point would be isn't he
childish for bringing one child food no
no because there's no obligation
no obligation but that is the argument
right some people would i'm not i'm not
saying he's wrong but what i am saying
is people would step forth and say well
he didn't provide for the other children
but even though even though he knew
when he got with this woman she's got
three other children she's potentially
obviously irresponsible come on look at
the facts he slept with a woman with
three children maybe from three
different men and he was cool with that
he took the risk he took that risk
knowing her behaviors
but we don't that
so do you think men shouldn't date
single moms then
well it's up to them as i'm talking a
lot guys come on um you know single
mothers you as a mature man as a person
with sense you gauge the situation you
can't just jump in and say boom i'm
gonna
i feel like as a man you can't win
because yeah if you
as a man if you don't bring food for the
child your waist man your idiot whatever
the rest of it if you bring chewed food
for your child now you need to look
after the rest how the hell did we work
that answer this question please and for
you paul what would you do in that
situation if you were the woman how
would you react i would let him take the
kid in the car
and give him the mcdonald's so you
wouldn't feel any time initially or or i
would take or i would take
responsibility for the kids that i made
get a job maybe not get my nails filled
and go buy the rest of them mcdonald's
okay but do you really think that we can
actually judge this woman and this
situation off of one incident that we've
all seen on the internet yeah that
everyone says everyone's saying that
she's got three kids from three
different people
we don't know that she can have three
kids from one guy and this is her second
relationship everybody should jump into
the conclusion that she's got three kids
from three different baby dads and
that's just sure what i'm saying what no
what i see is a pattern of behavior so
first i see you being irresponsible with
um
with the baby dads then i see you being
irresponsible because you're complaining
you don't have money and you have your
nails filled then i see you continuing
to be irresponsible because you're
you're throwing your kids food on the
ground and having a temper tantrum
online and then on top of that the
fourth fourth pattern of behavior is you
posted it yeah yeah so that's that's
like
she made a follow-up video oh and the
fifth fifth is that she made a fire at
the end
at the end of the day this is just more
[ __ ] excuses for women's behavior at
the end of the day
she did not
always all this crap about she was in an
emotional state no she physically got
her phone out of her pocket decided to
film it before he even turned up twice
the site twice and then decided to
humiliate yeah it may be clout but that
doesn't mean [ __ ] to me no no it doesn't
but that's the reality it might not mean
[ __ ] to you but the reality is like us
sitting here talking about it that's
exactly what she wanted to achieve and
make it a discussion and then this is
just from my perspective my reality is
that if that's my [ __ ] child i'm
providing for my [ __ ] job if you made
the mistake to have all these different
kids what obligation listen if you're
not giving it up to me anymore yeah
i'm i'm at the equation now yeah i would
do the bare minimum and the bare minimum
for me to do would be to provide for my
child at the end of the day if people
can
people can have their different opinions
that's fine but ultimately i think we'll
all have to agree that he
given that he had absolutely no
obligation and never will
that is the ultimate argument we can all
hate him for it we can all say he's
wrong but ultimately the fact that he
had no obligation i think past that
point anything else is just noise yeah
of course
he entertained it though he stood there
long enough to entertain it he for
example you said you wouldn't have a you
know if that was you in that situation
you would provide for your child but
from what you're saying i would gauge
that you wouldn't even have a child with
a woman like that oh absolutely i'll
listen in that sense they're both [ __ ]
up let's face it so this goes this goes
back further than the fact that you
turned up the door and she decided to
get cloud and film him yeah yeah this
goes back further than that but
ultimately
she's the one who [ __ ] up here by
filming that she didn't need to film
that she made an irresponsible decision
a calculated irresponsible decision to
film the situation and once again
society is excusing her he had no
obligation we're not excusing her no no
but she's wrong sorry just to rebuttal
that her whole follow-up video the first
thing she said is everyone's sending for
her and coming for her so obviously
people don't support what she's done
right
she yeah of course i agree i think it
was wrong that what she did but
the point for me is the fact that we as
people entertain it give it views this
is why it this is what drives people to
do these things and for me as a i'm not
a mother but if i was a mother i'm
thinking about my children who are young
who will be on the internet way more
than i would because you're emotionally
stable right
i'm very i try that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying you're
emotionally stable you want to do that i
try to be integral i try to be solvent i
try to be compassionate and i try to be
level-headed and balanced i don't think
either of them i can't really judge but
either of them are balanced for them to
have children because she even said oh
you've got kids or something along those
lines at some point she's got kids with
other people she's got kids with other
people
and it was for clown yeah
to feel that
that entitled that man should
essentially take care of the family
imagine if he comes and he gives us food
and he's like ah free up the puss now
i'm taking the care of your kids he's
like them guys
by one girl calamari they're like free
up on the first date
because before before he was before he
was in the running to be a step dad now
he's no longer in the running to be a
step dad why would he keep applying for
that position
i don't think he's just we've got we've
got two conflicting ideologies we've got
the modern woman versus the traditional
woman you you're being a modern woman
but you want traditional
archetypes yeah is that what we're
saying and we've got a man who has a
traditional biological position yeah
which is natural it's not something they
need to think about in a modern society
where women get the upper hand
so
we could we could sit here and if he
says biologically you look good and i'm
looking after your use three up it's a
mad conversation
that's a mad competition because
ultimately she's getting everything she
wants out of him but he's getting
nothing in return yeah yeah i think like
i said i think ultimately we can all
agree mm-hmm that they are both stupid
they're both they're both
but the only reason we're talking about
the only reason we're talking about this
right now the only reason we're
discussing this right now is because she
decided to be a [ __ ] and film it
which she said
she thought it was going to have a
counter a counter effect than what it's
actually had yes but i i agree with
pearl 100
that demonstrates something on a deeper
level about her mentality she's not that
stable to make a decision like that
and
like paul said she pointed out the fact
that she's got fake nails on but then
she's not able to
to feed her kids and she's worried about
this man i finna cuz i think mentally it
shows she's a [ __ ] idiot it just
she's not that stable in that moment
yeah no i have a moment because i feel
like sorry to interrupt i feel like
there are different things that
that different reasons as to why we'll
react a certain way about a certain
situation at any given time two moments
remember two videos two moments
two moments
which is fair which is fair because
again it's also a reaction based off of
other things and that's the reason why
she's done the second video what i'm
saying who cares but what i'm saying is
we're not we're not not every single
person every single time does everything
right by the books and that's what we're
trying to do
i do agree so that's if you make a
simple little mistake she went and made
the calculated decision to pull a phone
out of her pocket and film the whole
situation what what was it an accident
did her arms i agree with flimsy up and
decide to smack yourself why do you give
her an excuse at all
it's not an excuse i i do feel like she
made poor decisions but the bit where i
don't agree is that mentally unstable
because i feel like all right you're too
immature to look after so extreme
to say someone's mentally unstable based
off okay forget one forget mentally
understanding
exactly we all chase clout these
even if someone's getting stabbed the
first thing people do is get their phone
out yeah
why are they mentally unstable but i
still don't probably
say someone someone that was more
mentally unstable yeah okay and it's two
videos you're basing her whole life okay
every life decision you can you i mean
i've made probably 4 000 videos that are
on the internet you can't find me doing
[ __ ] like that because i'm mentally
stable go ahead like go go 4 000 videos
one at a time
and i'm and this is me i'm trying to get
clout i'm trying to build a platform
you're not gonna find it go ahead and i
just point out that she said something
about food stamps she's showing she's
insolvent as a person that means she
doesn't have the ability to manage money
no she doesn't make good choices to
manage money okay oh
she doesn't manage money well she has
four she makes prayer choices yes
yes i agree i agree with you yeah so you
have four children four months to feed
that are reliant on you you're on food
stamps you're insolvent
you're not solvent you're insolvent
then you've decided to become
emotionally charged about a situation
contextually i don't know the ins and
outs of but based on the video i can say
that you made a very very poor decision
to film one of your children's father
to belittle him in the presence of a
worldwide audience for clout and is that
not enough
and she doubled down on it yeah she
doubled the video
but
if you come this is the reality the
bodies okay let me say not say but
additionally
however what i do understand is people
who come from backgrounds that don't
have
the understanding so they're ignorant
they have ignorances they have lack of
education family structure they don't
know how to manage things in a mature
way in an adult way so
she's not gonna manage it in a way
that's adult this is a flat eye this is
the most beautiful example of an excuse
no it's not no i i know a lot of i know
a lot of people that came from really
bad backgrounds and had and had poor
family structures that don't do that
yeah of course i don't do that no i'm
not saying everybody but the reality of
it is we are looking at a generation
that is online she you don't know if
she's trying to generate funds you don't
know she's just trying to say okay okay
let's say she is who cares who cares
you're still selfish yeah like who cares
we understand that she's selfish and
mentally unstable no men
i think that's where we draw the line
no no that's fine right let's let's not
say she's mentally unstable would you
agree that she's not mature enough to
look off the kids yes
then potato potato that's ultimately
what we're saying i think she's
irresponsible i don't i can't say she's
um what do you say not mature enough to
look after children i you know she's on
food stamps she's yeah
yeah but that's pretty interesting
okay all right she's on food stamps now
she's on food stamps trying to take care
of all these kids why don't you just not
have all them [ __ ] kids
yeah if you actually do it if you've got
young children
the price that it i don't know how
expensive it must be in america but i
know in the uk a hundred percent to
have child care for your young children
is expensive and you have to i think you
have to work like a certain amount of
hours before you can get
that child care so if she's in a
position where she can't work and she
has to look after children she's going
to be in the position where she's going
to be in food stamps so it's kind of
like a vicious cycle well you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're okay
in the u.s you're literally paid to have
children out of wedlock they literally
give you money yeah i can't talk in the
u.s because i'm not gonna do this but i
don't know about the u.s but that's what
it's like in the u.s
ultimately it goes back further than
this
she's immature based on the decisions
she's made that have led to this moment
yeah but it thinks that
the rhetoric you're speaking and to be
honest with the most point i agree with
what you're saying but it's it's it's
dangerous in the sense of you're saying
that if someone even if they get
divorced and they end up being a single
mom that they're not emotionally mature
to look after their child that's the
thing that's not that's not what i'm
saying no i'm not i have i i have
relatives i got divorced and they got
remarried and they're emotional and they
wouldn't
take out a phone
yeah record that like i emotionally
unstable
i am directly linking to the video it's
not because she's
talking to him he was talking about the
decision she made
makes her immature leading up before the
decision she made before makes her
immature to look after her child but if
she was married before and had the
children married
yeah because the definition of baby dad
who's the dad of your baby
typically you're not from the u.s but
typically you say ex-husband
that's typically what you say that's my
ex-husband no but i'm telling you like
i'm from the u.s that's the term we use
it's ex-husband or baby daddy we know
what u.s people do
it seems like
she was not married before she had these
kids
and then on top of that you have the
video like you have all of these
different pieces of information that say
you know she's probably not stable
enough to have children they are a sign
of her immaturity i agree with the video
100 percent she but in terms of her
all because she made the poor choice of
say before she had a child out of
wedlock and she's not with the guy
that's not saying any person has a child
outside of wedlock is not mature enough
to have a child you can't say you can
say it based on the video but you can't
say on it based on that from before what
what
what if she didn't marry the first one
didn't marry the second one she's now
got kids but that's an assumption you
don't know if all three weren't from all
right no no that's fine because if there
was three kids versus just that sorry if
there was three kids that means there'd
be two dads we don't know if it was uh
yeah kids were found right but at the
bare minimum it shows that she would
have if she's not being married at all
that shows that she's had sex and had
kids out of weddings because i'm but i'm
the point is that you are responsible
for your decisions no no so
you're you're responsible for your own
decision so if you make those decisions
that's your bad lie in it like i'm just
tired of women being bailed out for
their poor decisions
you can say that i'm trying to be
balanced here guys poor decisions the
man lying with a woman with three
children made a poor decision
unprotected sex he didn't he didn't and
he's being responsible by giving the kid
food yep that's exactly what he's doing
and he ain't pulling a phone out he's
not he's not [ __ ] no no no but my
point is before we get to the child
being there yeah
there was three children before this
child right we know this this is
something we know from the information
provided which is not his responsibility
i'm not saying it is his responsibility
i agree it might not be his
responsibility
but knowing that information he still
laid with her he still he still accepted
that he could potentially have a
childhood with her which he did and he's
taking care of his child yeah yeah he's
well he's attempting to by feeding
feeding him or her mcdonald's yeah which
isn't nutritious but we get
we won't get into that i'll get under
that house yeah exactly he's doing the
best he can with the resources he's got
we appreciate that
but at the same time before we get to
the child being born you still have you
had information
available to you that you did not use in
my opinion appropriately to make a good
decision yourself who are we talking
about the
i'm not relinquishing accountability at
all what i am saying is as as a
a couple as a partnership they both had
a part to play now he's in a situation
he doesn't need to be in because of a
sick individual if you want to put it
with that
he has no part to play in in looking
after we're getting so far away from the
subject matter we
look at the end of the day we see this
all the time yeah people who split up
they're not married they have loads
because we see that everywhere at what
point did anyone need to pull a phone
out and film that situation and be
little the man live on camera chuck the
food on the floor
ultimately let's just let's just get
back to the video
and defend it later she made two videos
consciously and calculated he went
through that whole process to make those
videos that's ultimately the crux of the
subject and the point and the point and
the point is and the point is and the
point is this is my show and the point
is
that that that equates there should be a
consequence for that and honestly like
mothers should be afraid to do this
there's no consequence to women doing
this she should have a consequence in
court if i was the baby dad i would take
that to court and she should have full
custody but there is no fear because
women won't lose that battle let's just
spite the spider exactly yeah
do you think one instant one incident
two all right two incidents
i don't know how old this child is but
do you think that is enough to
give over custody just those two videos
are enough to allow a mother to lose
custody of her yes yeah 100 percent yeah
i think men have it much worse i think
they'll get their they'll get their
they'll get their kids taken for much
worse do you think that's enough for
anyone to like okay let's take away the
fact that she's a woman do you think
that's enough for anyone to have their
children taken away
with that level of immaturity 100 yeah
because if a man gets caught on video
just once slapping his child too hard
they're going to see your domestic
abusers
those examples are so yeah they're so
fast
let's get let's get real for a second
because what you guys are saying is so
extreme on the other end like we agree
that she's not responsible we agree i
can agree with you she's immature i can
even say she's a [ __ ] cool
but
emotionally unstable to the point where
she gets her children taken off her
that's just so extreme okay is it
extreme is it extreme to have four
children by at least two different dads
it's not because
not it's not think about how many people
i'm out of wedding
it happens but that doesn't matter one
at a time guys one at a time sorry i
think like we keep saying like out of
wedlock like we're actually putting
value on marriage what about if this
person does the best for the kids best
for the family how do okay
how many marriages last year yeah how
many marriages last and also like
how who are we to say that that's the
right choice for them like
if she didn't want to get married she
didn't want to get married but if she
was married and that situation ended
like we're putting this massive emphasis
on marriage when really it doesn't well
i think the father being in the home
should be the most important thing and
so the question is why did like if she
was married and that happened my
question would be why did it end because
70 to 80 of the time women leave why did
you leave
why did you why'd you put your feelings
above the kids that's an assumption
that's an assumption no it's based off
of data statistics so it's based off of
data if you're college educated the
chance that you get divorced you leave
is 90
the chance that you leave a marriage yes
90 as a woman if you're a college
educator if you're college educated it's
90 and 70 to 80 so women leave much more
than men do it's not an assumption it's
based on data but we're talking about
this one woman
you asked me what it would be if she was
married and i said if she was married to
more than one person my question would
be why
why was she married no why did why did
it end and typically it's the woman that
leaves i know but you asked what would
happen if that happened and i'm giving
you an answer
but honestly like why does it matter why
it ended how do we know that it and it
didn't end because sorry it did end
because he was abusive or how do we know
that well why is that where your mind
goes abuse i don't know i'm just like
yeah
but there's no there's no it's the same
way that you're saying that oh why did
you leave like why didn't you care about
this no because i have i have data to
back that up you don't there's no
there's no data that men are abusing
women left and right that that's that's
the statement that women make the
accusations no actually and actually in
most domestic violence cases are mutual
so both parties are beating up each
other and actually women abuse men more
than men abuse women that is
one-sided okay
can we go back to this woman yeah yeah
let's go
because i feel like there's certain
things that's been said that's been like
we're kind of talking past each other
with certain points that we're all
making and i think
in a way we kind of all agree that she's
crazy mm-hmm can we all say that we all
agree that she's crazy yes the bit where
i feel like we split hairs a little bit
is the fact that
we're going to the extreme end of she
needs to lose her children yeah and i
don't agree with it how many times in
your life have you made a mistake
do you need to be penalized yeah there
should be consequences for mistakes so
yes so do you feel like there's been a
mistake that you've made in your life
that you should have been extremely
penalized for
not really hmm are you perfect yeah i
completely decided i'm not i'm not
working no no i'm saying i'm not perfect
i'm just trying to think of something
i've done to that equivalent can i bring
up a good example here right on the flip
side so she made the calculated decision
to whack the phone out and go through
this whole process right
now this man like say for example
this man
cheated on her which was a calculated
decision to go out
go to a bar knowing that there'd be
women there with the intention to sleep
with them
he sleeps with another woman cheeks on
her she doesn't like it she [ __ ] him
off and then he loses his kids
how is it any different
at a principal level it is no different
it's no different
what's that
principle is no difference
he was highly emotional when he fell
into it
we've got to excuse him he was running
off of emotion it's absolute [ __ ]
this is all just excuses
got to my head i just did it yeah i have
too much testosterone it doesn't [ __ ]
matter if she takes him to conferences
i'm leaving if he cheated on me i'm
taking the kids
the judge is going to stamp it and go
right you that's it that's fine and to
me this is on the other side you don't
see that we're justifying them so higher
though the stakes are higher the stakes
are higher yeah why because she's taking
the kids
in this scenario he's not taking any
sorry i can hear me yeah so he's not she
he's not taking any child he's bringing
food which is supposed to add
to the she made this she made the steaks
higher she made the steaks higher by
making it a national story well she
didn't know she didn't make it a
national story
by uploading it she filmed it and
uploading it she had the intent for it
to go viral
okay can you answer answer this question
did she film it of course did she did
she upload it of course did she know
that it could go viral by putting it on
the internet
did she delete it after i don't know no
she didn't even delete it why would she
though
it's true she's wrong but you just do
but but you just said she you just don't
know earlier you made an excuse for her
you said she didn't know she did yes yes
we could revive the tape you did say you
she didn't know it would go viral and
i'm saying she didn't know
it couldn't it didn't have to go by i
know but she could have deleted it after
the first reaction video and she did it
yeah but no one knows the video is
no that's fine that's one
thank you very much stop stop if you've
got a girlfriend and you take a mistress
on a date you don't know if you're going
to chop but you might end up chopping
but you still don't get intention
so we agree you don't know if it's going
to go can i ask you a question can i ask
you a question if i try and shoot
someone it misses you does that mean
that i don't go down for attempted
murder yeah
she knew that there was a higher likely
chance it would go viral that's all that
matters yeah that's all that matters but
the stakes are different going back to
you it's because she's a woman woman
for a woman
the snakes are different
excuses
i'm not making excuses we are making
excuses
i could make a compilation from this
like video of just like this i'm going
to do this i'm going to cut it i'm not
making excuses and do a cut to every
single excuse
it's not an excuse it's the reality that
i mean
the stakes are different
because she's a woman
no in the situation the stakes are
actually different
we are talking about a man bringing
mcdonald's for his child yeah no sorry
yeah
yeah we are like why is it that deep and
then we're talking about a woman posting
this on the internet yeah that's what
we're talking about i know right that's
part of what we're talking about
of course yeah she wanted to belittle
him in a w in a worldwide audience we
understand that's wrong right and it's
wrong we agree we agree no i agree this
happens
a lot this has happened more than once
there's um cases that haven't gone viral
etc etc but what i'm saying going back
to your point
um back to your point my brain has
frozen but back to your point being
i have some whiskey
nerves no no it's not nerves it's about
um
my brain has just frozen we're trying to
equivalent to cheating oh yeah that's it
right so the stakes for the man are
different from the woman in this
situation so the guy is bringing food
she didn't like the situation she filmed
it for clout we understand that the man
cheating on the woman has nothing to do
with the kids it has nothing to do with
the man bringing something into the
household that wasn't my point though if
we were talking about my point that
wasn't my point i'm talking in prince in
principle
if we're gonna justify that it was just
emotional she was in an emotional state
by whacking out the camera and
intentionally filming it to over time
twice uploading them with the intention
for it to go viral
and we're justifying that
there's no different than me turning
around and justifying a man for
consciously going out there and making a
calculated decision to cheat because you
would leave him over that and you'd go
that's inexpensive are you facing it
though it doesn't matter she filmed it
because she's a prick
i'm saying ultimately we excuse women
far more she did not need to film that
she made she made the calculated
decision to do that and if he made the
calculated decision to cheat you
wouldn't hear the end of it you'd be
like no it's done it's over you wouldn't
give them the time of day right and
you'd say you going back to your
previous points all of you right you
made a mistake
is that the billing and all
yes it's the field and then of course
gender has absolutely everything to do
[Laughter]
i mean you got the nail polish
it's totally different it's totally
different
in my position it's totally different
the fakes are totally different i think
when it comes to
children being involved with men and
women i think we always discuss this and
it's like from the point of the fact the
fact that the woman
is the person that carries the baby
i don't care what law favors the woman
more i'm sorry but it should be like
that because as a man what did you do
for nine months no wait what law should
favor the i don't know whatever
whatever law or whatever thing you think
might favor a woman more than a man what
did a man do when it comes to con um
carrying a baby that's irrelevant how do
i
no no no
it's not irrelevant in terms of the fact
you you when it comes to having children
i'm saying the reason why i feel like
women are more favored in in certain
cases is because the woman is the one
that carried the kids
i just want to clarify something so you
think that the law should look at
someone through the basis of sex and
favor them on the basis of sex you're
you're you're taking it a totally
different way that's based on what
you're saying
no no i'm i'm i'm clarifying what you're
saying i'm saying that you are saying
i'm saying let's stay on the statement i
said based off the fact that the woman's
the one that carries a baby for nine
months and
you you've put in work you've put in
time the man didn't really put in time
like what time did he not put in by
making a wage to go and provide for them
no no no
i'm asking you the question should
should the lot no no no guys guys
this is my show come on this i'm asking
you the question yes or no should the
law favor
like look at someone through the basis
of their sex
in this case when it comes to children
should they favor the woman when it
comes to children i think so certain
things certain things i think so okay
that's that's just what i think
when it comes to children we need a
separate podcast for this we need a
separate book when it comes to have when
it comes to children but only don't you
but don't you go 50 50 on a baby like
like in terms of having a child not
being all over not everything
being able to produce a baby and
actually give birth is the lowest end of
the skill in terms of a man actually has
to go there and yeah produce a wage to
provide that's a much harder skill than
just eating your legs
dogs give no no no guys guys guys guys
dogs give birth dogs give birth the jobs
so ultimately so ultimately you're
saying she should get the ultimate
excuse no because she because she can
bear a child you're basically saying
every time but here's what you're saying
right to clarify because she's the one
who carries the child for nine months
she should get the upper hand that is
literally what you're saying things
there are certain things like what i
don't
but i just you can't say no no you can't
do that if you're gonna make such a
statement you need to buy you need to
provide backup come on back it up
back it up give me an example back up
no no no no no no you you don't change
the subject come on are you a little bit
that's a girl thing
at the end of the day this is ultimately
all about it's just excusing a woman yet
again it's not it's about no i i need an
example
i need an example the reason why
give me an example let me speak let me
speak the reason why i can't give you
like an example is because when you're
comparing
a woman having a child to a dog having a
child there is no conversation
it's so different
can you do it no so how is it no
no do it no no stop please
let me speak to this man here how is it
a low-end skill if you cannot do
something she can't impregnate herself
so where are you going with this it's
not but we're not talking about yes you
can that part of it we are talking about
the fact that
that's the whole that's the whole
premise of getting pregnant yeah but
we've gone away from that we're talking
about carrying the actual babies for
nine months is it a skill of 50 of the
population can do something but they
can't yes they can there's a lot of
women that come here actually women make
up more than 50. that's the exception to
the rule
that's exceptional let's go back on
topic anyway but how many man make money
though because i guarantee you can i can
i can i just ask you what based on you
based on what you're saying do you think
that the fact that she can carry the
child that the man's investment in that
is nil compared to hers i didn't say
that but
you're insinuating that that's what
you're insinuating i didn't i'm telling
you i didn't say it but
i'm
so what do you think about it i i do
feel like the man obviously mate
obviously the man's involved obviously
all of that stuff but you'll give but
you're giving the woman the upper hand
here it's not the upper hand i just feel
like when there are certain things
you're going right back on yourself
when certain things happen
when when it involves um women and
children and a man there are certain
things that should favor the woman a
little bit more because more time it's
the man that's going to walk away how
many single moms do you know how many
how many people do you know that don't
have dads did you not just hear pearls
state the fact that 70 to 80 of women
are the ones who walk away
during when they're married sorry that's
what she said
when they're married
why did you get pregnant from a man
you're not married with anyone when you
know
that's what you value though
no it's what's best for the children so
it's quite it's it's quite selfish to
build a family based on you and not your
kids exactly and if you're not 100
certain that you're going to stick with
a guy because let's face it don't
[ __ ] me and tell me that woman women
go into relationship not thinking that
the same better will come along or i
could leave this man at any point and i
will absolutely be favored we all know
that that's the case right
so
i again i think ultimately to honestly
to just go back on everything all i'm
hearing is excuse after excuse yet again
to favor women
for me it's about taking accountability
where accountability needs to be taken
on both the man and the woman's side
what he's doing after his child he's
looking after child how about they don't
take accountability sorry how about you
take accountability by not filming such
a stupid [ __ ] situation and we agree
on it
we agree on that aspect but my point is
before that whole situation happen we do
not have context we do not have
understanding we're running off of this
woman being very irresponsible immature
insolvent these are things that we know
we don't know anything sorry paul we
don't know anything about this man
his face is blocked out obviously people
know them and know their dynamic we do
not we are facilitating the sharing of
this video we are indulging in it we're
passing judgment on it and we're
contributing contributing to the problem
you know do you know why
you know what i was looking forward to
okay i've been talking a lot today yeah
we are much quieter but
it's burning me
and also
for for
for the sake of the podcast
what is the solution
yeah i want to know what the solution is
because we can all jump and say this and
that but what's the solution give the
dad custody oh that's the why
why how is that because because she
because she you asked me a question i'm
going to answer it thank you okay
because she proved to be mentally
unstable
in all of the ways that i listed by
making not one but two videos on top of
that you can't afford food but you have
your nails done what what type of mom
are you um
um and then on top of that she defended
the video how do i know that she didn't
do her nails herself how did i know that
her auntie didn't do her nose how do i
know that her sister doesn't do a weave
how do i know
this is okay so let me let me get this
straight she didn't
the nails the lashes and the weave
how much is mcdonald's what what costs
more i don't listen i don't know
listen to what no but my point is i
don't know context because
for example i've got my nose done i have
a job etc yeah but i can do my own nose
i don't have four kids but i have no i
don't know i know i know but my point is
how do i know her sister didn't do her
nose for free how do i know that how how
do you you you don't exactly but you can
make you can make an assumption
based up based on like
all of these pieces of information that
show she's not responsible let me ask
you let me ask you questions
and what's that what do you do
what do you think she's supposed to buy
the weave
mcdonald's is like five dollars forget
forget
forget the assumption what do you think
forget whether you forget whether there
is an assumption that her sister could
have done it someone could have done it
with what do you honestly think
what what typically would you actually
assume i would personally assume that
she was irresponsible enough to go and
pay for all that first of all i
try not to divulge in these kind of
videos because it makes me have a
negative perspective of the world that's
the first thing but also to get back to
your point i don't i see you i see you
doing hand gestures
for me personally i
my assumption i
maybe because of who i am
i know people that do these things so
they keep up appearances like a lot of
people online we can all say that people
keep up appearances for online clout
she could have fixed up herself just to
do the video i need to go on her page
and observe how she actually is or see
her in real life i can't i don't want to
because this is all assumption to me all
of this is assumption on my part
assuming that she's you can't make any
assumptions based on evidence no no no
no
my my position i i can take
accountability that my position and you
know her her response to the situation
is based on assumption
your position is based on assumption
and stereotypes with evidence
the same everywhere look we're all
looking at the same evidence but we're
perceiving it very different we're all
drawing different parts of the items
i'll give you another piece of that i'll
give you i'll give you another piece of
evidence the interior of her car looked
a lot better than the baby daddy's
interior of his car there's another
piece of evidence yeah but we'll have a
question so it indicates that maybe
she's not good with money well i said
that earlier
and and yeah so then why are you then
why are you saying oh well if she's if
we agree that she's likely insolvent why
are you giving her all these excuses for
how she that's all it is at the end of
the day
we're basing it on her physical
appearance
that's what we're talking about i was
talking about her being insolvent
because she's on food stamps
she she's on food stamps
exactly we're basing that based on her
appearance what are we basing the fact
that she pulled the phone out and made
the calculated decision to make a
[ __ ] stupid move what are we what
excuse me
it shows that she's irresponsible
i think we should all i think we should
all just see the obviously listen please
how do we know this
this
great guy that i just bought seven
pounds mcdonald's
is mad responsible let me finish let me
finish
how is it that he has not decided to
take his child in the first place when
he decided to leave the woman
because let me finish because if i was
if i always say this
if i have if i have a child with someone
wedlock nowhere whatever i'm fighting
for my child because of how i grew up
and how most of my my guys grew up with
no fathers so why is it that this man
seven pounds mcdonald's oh so
responsible why is he not decided to say
okay you just said earlier you just
argued earlier that that women should be
favored in the justice system and they
are so you you might fight for your kid
but when it's eighty percent chance that
she's gonna win
there's not there's nothing
i know i know i know but you're not to
win that's the problem you could be more
worried about you can tell you would you
could you could believe that that's easy
that's easy to say when you've never had
to fight with a kid
and and that's what i'm saying i'm
saying like there's there's a lot of
fathers that aren't that had kids with
crazy moms right that's on them sure
fine but the court doesn't represent
them yeah and the court doesn't advocate
for men
and you even advocated earlier that
that's okay so even when there's a crazy
mom they they get a favor they should
get they get favored in court and that's
what happens eighty percent of the time
they win right now you're using stats to
defend men that are not responsible
because no that's not what i'm saying
that's not what this is based this is
because you're saying something that's
not true that's not what i said this is
based off my reality and the people that
i'm around okay none of us know our
fathers uh-huh why there's there's
reasons for that because
you're gonna say oh well why did she
reproduce with a man that wasn't a
father
his feelings based off
reality based on your previous stuff a
lot of people's reality but based on
your previous statement you just said
with that attitude you won't win no you
can go in there with all the confidence
in the world you're not going to win
because statistics speak louder you know
you know they're they're a man like
there's still a higher chance bro right
but what are you what are you no that's
not how life works
listen i'll tell you what the next
listen i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what that's how i see like the next time
i tell you approach the edge of a cliff
and jump off and if someone says 20
chance you're surviving let's see what
you do then uh but and that's why i love
you and you because you have those
extreme
analogies and views but that's what the
statistics are saying that's what the
stats are no stat will say if you drop
off a cliff yeah you've got 20 percent
chance of living i'm sorry yeah i'm
sorry
you
you use the livestream based on
contraception because it's like one
percent ineffective they said it was
like 80 you wouldn't do it would you so
that's not an extreme
you're negating the point at the end of
the day so are you guys no no the print
the principle is your attitude is if i
go in there with the
with the attitude that i will win this
case you're thinking you'll win
not just
an attitude you're not going to go to
court with justin's attitude you go over
a little bit more than that bro come on
can i can i give you a little insight
into like what fathers go through so
like if if a man's kicked out of the
home right and like maybe he's taking
like they're fighting a lot and he
decides to leave okay she can withhold
the kids from him so he can't see them
and she can and she can call the police
when he comes to grab his children and
they won't give him to her right or to
him
then let's say it takes six months to
get to court it takes a couple months
like covet something happens she can say
that he's the kid he's not in the kids
lives then she gets automatic custody on
top of that he can be on the hook for
child support for 25 of his
discretionary income so that's the
income he makes after taxes so a guy and
and he he might have to spend 20 30
dollars trying to fight to even get the
kids in the first place so and the
average guy makes forty five thousand
dollars per year so that's fifty percent
of his income men men suicide rates when
it comes to divorce are much higher than
women's
because of things like this
and so it's not as easy if oh just get
it have a good attitude and go in and do
it like the the court system favors yeah
but he said
you're not putting it that simple i've
never said it was that easy but can i
say something the cool as i said now in
in the last podcast that i was on the
court system by design is a business if
a woman is is more likely to get legal
aid that is coming out of our tax money
if you work that's your tax money men
are less likely to get legal aid thus
they pay for it it's a business
transaction let me ask you a question
do you think biology has nothing to do
with that
no i know that it's about traditional
roles the british i don't want to say us
because i don't really know about u.s
structural they've got very
uh politically in my opinion politically
politically incorrect positions
um but the uk judicial system is based
on traditional family roles the man
being the provider the mother being the
nurturer and a home
home keeper what do they call it home
homemade homemaker right so that
traditional balance is what the uk
judicial system is based upon regardless
of your position as a woman if you have
children and you earn below a certain
amount or you don't work you are more
likely to get legal aid and as a working
woman i've gone through the court system
for other reasons i was not entitled to
legal aid and it's very difficult and
it's very stressful when you're paying a
lot of money to get things done
it's down to the man's sheer willpower
alone that will get him for a court case
but this is a business transaction the
longer the man is paying in to the
judicial system they prefer it because
you're feeding the
the balance they prefer what
they prefer that men are in these cases
with women right and it's beneficial for
the judiciary
but that shows that it is a is a femme
centric system that is set up designed
to favor the woman no but this is
it's not about but it's a traditional
system
before based on the patriarchy isn't
traditional staying together like the
mother and the
as father said as you said we're living
in a modern society right with
traditional foundations okay and just
like this woman here she wants
traditional actions from this man but
she wants to live as you would call it
the modern woman lifestyle right having
multiple kids with multiple guys not
being married all these things now
the perspective is up to the viewer
right going back to the video the
perspective is up to the viewer about
who she is and how she presents yeah do
we agree on that yes
but what perspective because what the
perspective you're trying to reach out
is that
he's got to still carry on provide
providing for the kids no no no no my
position is everybody takes
accountability for their part to play
now i don't know the man's part to play
in this based on the video
you know it could be argued he's wrong
he should provide for all the kids just
because
no no no no no no we've said this
already to because it builds animosity
amongst children that they're one of
their siblings is getting frustrated
but that's her problem
yeah that is her problem but
it affects the children right everyone
we agree that it affects the children as
a business decision if i know your house
is going to get repossessed and i want
to buy it at a discount i know morally i
could put your kids out on the street
that's not my problem i've got nothing
to do with you of course but we're
talking about our man and children are
integrity
no no
it's about having integrity and having
family it is about integrity right his
child could potentially be isolated uh
be treated in ill will because his
mother is the one that looks after him
the most most of the time assuming it
sounds like you're making the case for
him to get custody
listen to what i'm saying he could be
argued
it could be argued he could be argued
i'm making a case for him to get custody
but my point is his behavior is
contributing to the problem right
him bringing his kid mcdonald's no
you're you're just bypassing everything
i said you know i'm trying to make a
balanced argument okay
so
he's so he's saying he's just i don't
want to hear balance i want to hear what
you really think like
everyone's got conflict everyone's got
conflicting views so when you bring
balance into the equation it's not
telling me what you generally
no i'm telling you what i truly think
because i look at it for what it is i do
not know i do not have enough
information to draw a straight line
conclusion about the situation with
these two people i don't so you give her
the benefit of the doubt
foreign anyone the benefit of the doubt
that's balanced i don't know the answer
i'm using
we can all agree that they're both in
the wrong right yeah because yeah
because
at the end of the day i did say
if you come to a house where there's
children
there's children there man no but that's
the no
that's that's where i would disagree he
wasn't wrong he he was in the right for
providing for his child on an integral
level you'll disagree but
from a principal standpoint he had no
obligation he doesn't exactly and we
agree but at the same time if you're
coming to a place where there's children
but now the emotions are involved it's
just i believe this
listen if you come to my house and i
don't offer you a drink yeah as a decor
i'm a prick but you shouldn't feel
entitled i didn't offer you a drink
sometimes when we're saying certain
things you are going way back to just
this are you thinking we disagree we
agree with everything you are saying
we're saying there's the other side to
the story which is what she's trying to
do there's a side where we completely
agree that she's a prick she's a [ __ ]
she's irresponsible she's there she's
that but there's the other side to it
the man you can look at the lens from
both sides you can look at the mana zone
be like yo but i can see your side and
think you're wrong yeah of course of
course because your agenda is set out
that the woman is wrong it's not it's
not good
this is my show this is this is my show
you're gonna say it i don't i say it how
i see it exactly she was wrong it's not
an agenda it's it's i saw a situation
she was wrong i don't think i think the
man was right in this situation because
he's providing for a child can i just
argue the fact that all of the the
reason she made that second video to say
that i'm responding to everybody coming
at me i think that proves that it almost
takes common sense to see that she was
flat out in the wrong i think i think
we're just going past all the
obviously
she got backlash she's wrong because of
delivery she's wrong because she pulled
out the phone yeah she's wrong because
she's entitled yeah but that does not
mean that the man isn't wrong either but
when i say that you don't say it's
emotions but it's it's assumption it's
assumption we don't know anything at
this point what we do know is he turned
up with food for his child where he had
no obligation to take care of any other
child and she decided to pull her phone
out and make the calculated decision to
fill him and humiliate him and whack
food on the floor that is that is based
on the actual facts that we see any any
different views on that and i'd say that
you're brain dead i'm sorry but anything
other than that is emotion
we all have a shared
view
and i think that
in this situation it's very uh
complicated
now we can look at it no no no no
display to be honest yeah you're trying
to make it complex
no you're trying to make it so that your
point is highlighted right it's
objective yeah yeah yeah it's objective
at the end of the day anything other
than objectivity here everything else is
noise yeah but at the end of the day
like you said it's assumption yeah it's
emotion though
i'll make it uh i'm gonna start to use
that line no no no no but the all of the
the viewpoints here are all assumptions
this is all assumptions we are viewers
we are viewers we don't know the facts
in real terms we are making an
assumption based on the perspective that
we're coming from now we all have
different backgrounds yeah we all have
different experiences we all have
different understandings and my position
as i said i'm trying to be balanced and
i'm trying to look at it
in the reality of i don't know what this
woman's been through i don't know why
she did what she did i don't know why he
did what he did
when he's just as a man who cares it
doesn't matter it's justified
who cares but you're here discussing it
that's the that's the reality of it is
it right because we talk about because
the reason we bring up situations like
this is the representative of the larger
society there's a lot of men
there's a lot of there's there's a lot
of men that go through [ __ ] every day
like this yeah and they know what it's
like to have a crazy baby mom when
they're not doing anything wrong and
there he's he's doing the right thing he
is providing for his child and you are
still finding a way to criticize it no
no no no no no no no we agree no you
just you just said a little bit ago that
you could argue that he should have
brought mcdonald's for all of the kids
and and they can't seem to be
and that's and that's what i'm saying
i'm saying a man can do everything right
and still get criticized no no but
they're not doing everything right
okay
i wanna hear what you gotta say oh no i
just don't think he's doing everything
right like if you put it into context
i think majority of people would say
that he should have brought food
for the kids and other people say that
he shouldn't have but we don't know if
he's doing everything right in that
video with the evidence that you've got
you could possibly say yes because he's
bringing a child food for his child but
we don't know if he's doing everything
right she's working she's moving off
some sort of emotion obviously she's not
right in what she's done and i agree
with you both she's totally out of order
for what she's done but like we said we
don't have the facts and we don't have
all the evidence to say that this hasn't
built up to something but we can assume
that it has but i'm saying based off of
what we've seen in this video he was
doing everything right
yeah and yeah and yet there he was doing
a lot right he was everything
he was doing a lot right i'll give you
he was doing 90 right but there's other
kids in the room bring some more chips
that's intense that's the integrity this
is this is where this is like this is
where the emotion comes in though is it
it's all about integrity
most of the viewers watching we can see
this by the response she's got it
doesn't matter what we assume and what
we believe is integral what we do know
is he he came along and he provided for
his child had no other he had no other
reason to do any anything otherwise
that's all ultimately that's all that
matters anything else is just it's just
noise and in which all this integrity is
amazing but because we're having a
discussion but the integrity doesn't
matter the integrity doesn't matter
no no the reason why i'm saying no is
because if we're having a discussion and
there are people that are looking at one
side of the of the um grain thinking the
woman is dead wrong and they stop there
then there is no fair comparison on both
sides for me i'm saying to you i agree
with you the woman is completely wrong
100 wrong
but you can look at the other side and
say the man there's kids here you could
have brought more food simple it's the
kid part you could have brought more
food for the kids the woman's wrong i
agree with you the woman is so response
her reaction is wrong everything the way
she died she didn't manage the situation
like a mature adult she inflated the
issue in a negative way which is
irresponsible
inexcusable it's inexcusable because as
a part a part of being an adult is being
able to discern the situation and
identify is this appropriate for this
time and place if the answer is no you
shouldn't do it and you know what you
know what i agree that all of that would
be great i i do agree with all of that i
do
know up to the point up to the point
where the camera gets involved
up to the point where the camera gets
involved that's the reason why we're
here we wouldn't know about the
situation everything you were saying i i
fully i give it the weight i really do i
think you're right in saying a mature
adult will consider all aspects i do
agree right but
yeah no that's fine that's fine
but up until the point
which is the reason why we're here the
[ __ ] whacked out a camera and was a
prick and decided that i'm gonna try and
make this man go viral for being an
[ __ ] that's why we're here anything
else is just noise i'm being objective
here and i'm sure i'm sure deep down
anybody listening to this podcast let's
look at the comments please i guarantee
you anybody will sit here and say that's
all that matters here okay speaking of
comments we're going to read super chat
um okay guys um you guys should
sign up for our memberships because we
are going to turn on our members only
chat for the second half of the stream
um all these super chats are being
donated towards ish get issue camera
let's go i know y'all want to see what
ish looks like he's a good looking guy
behind the camera but you would never
know because you can't see him so send
some donations and we will get isha
camera and the way it works is youtube
pays you out by the month so we're
trying to get as many donations as
possible this month so we can get a
camera at the end of next month okay so
let's get a gofundme going
yeah get is the camera okay put the
first campaign
okay okay so bret okay there's a lot of
super chat so this is going to take a
second if any of you guys have to go to
the bathroom go now because there's a
lot of super chats yeah okay okay so
brit cormier since drones are not
following us around 100 of the time the
excuse will always say we do not know
all of the facts no way to win the an
argument that way with people that think
that all info must be known siro
cryomancer lol integrity she's got three
other kids why doesn't she have food for
them and where are their fathers wendell
coven hey pearl paul how many of us
think he should have brought food for
all the kids
jacob mackenzie can we do that jess look
if we can actually do a poll in the chat
just i'm just curious um jacob mckenzie
huge fan of your show pearl keep it up
this is the episode i can tell you can
tell a lot about a man in his shoes
radit tier 2 worry
ffs he is trying to feed his kid it is
is that so hard to understand he comes
every other day which means he is a good
dad since he is bringing mcdonald's
maybe he is not rich he cannot afford to
provide
for every child in that home he is it
right in every respect allenster horton
more evidence that emotion is a weakness
brit cormier willpower hell that is not
true it takes wallet power the state
makes money exploiting the father to the
mangina in orange there is no such thing
as your reality or my reality reality is
objective how your view of it is
subjective credit to myron however i
would bet that bitcoin that your average
views a woman will take advantage of you
johnny17202
dude in the back right keeps talking
over pearl man's gotta chill dude in the
orange gets too emotional for this
conversation facts over feelings wayne
williams i spent 26 000 i spent 26 000
pounds trying to get my son and i still
lost justin j smooth dude in the orange
is all emotional sentience to the beta
to the beta orange female the courts the
courts in the u.s heavily favor women
over men because of the bias still
thinks women are better for children
than than men despite stats showing that
single mother homes have a huge
disadvantage for the kids journey to pro
prosperity bro or bro and orange is
crazy no man should talk like him
journey to prosperity two two
two i'm orange is crazy amazon weighed
wave alone cost weave alone cost 200
plus no matter if she pays for the
installation or get it's done for free
gus he said on the video he goes every
other day zen yeah that's a ton of money
sentience to the the beat nick next to
the to the beat nick next to the weak
orange beta female yes you should avoid
these type of videos and debates bury
your head in the sand so to speak
because that's how we all should go
through life conflict divorce avoidance
rather than accepting responsibility
miguel bermudez i wish we could do a
call in live show to give our opinions
guys we are trying to figure out the
audio for colin
we're hoping to get it figured out this
week i don't
yeah well hopefully
the original black karen thank you for
the super chat sentience to the woman in
the middle despite men simping for your
beauty your logic like your pants are
colorful but off points you said women
can get pregnant without a man a man
needs to release his seed for any
pregnancy sentience there are certain
things claimed by a weak beta female
i guess
there are certain things claimed made by
a weak beta female you lost your man
card who cannot back up an argument
aside for emotion having a debate is a
skill for intelligent people true men
think before think then speak before
wait true men think speak before they
speak
ada ladies this ladies the simp in red
is an easy target you could play him
sentient simp on the left next to the
beat neck what did a man do for nine
months let me ask you what did the woman
do for 18 years the man protects
provides and supports the woman wouldn't
carry the baby without the man's seed
some male feminists are weak johnny 17
202 202. cheating leaves the kids out of
it and receives a higher rate of
punishment she said his kids don't eat
if the others don't eat sounds like
child neglect
tr166a he wanted it she wanted it to go
viral she thought she was right
sibo m-c-u-b-e
to the
to those excusing the woman i would be
surprised if cps stops by does an
investigation and gets those kids taken
away due to the fact that she's shown an
inability to take care of her kids in
that video ata the
the one in the white captain excuses one
on the left sentience riddle me this in
the u.s women are incentivized to leave
men if divorce and alimony if children
are involved there is child support even
if that woman is not married she is
being paid for children from the
government what is she doing with that
money miguel bermudez per the cdc women
on women on women domestic violence is
the highest
tr166a remember she said that his child
does not get to eat then she remember
she said that his child does not get to
eat then if he does not cater to the
children that are not his what do you
call that ata i'm from l.a baby daddy is
out for all of us who have kids outside
of marriage sibo
nc cube she's got at least three baby
daddies she spoke about them in the
plural to the man that that was in your
video yo pearl hit me up you me and
sarah can light a a p-hub
why would you do that to me guys stop it
um
monkey yousap y'all are sad for
defending this woman you really are
giving her every excuse send the
asteroid the world is done gavin blood
there are excuses if you get arrested
for breaking a law you didn't know about
the officer is going to tell you that
not knowing about the law is not an
excuse sentience to the people who said
who are excusing her baby daddy let's
say that she
might have been in relationships with
her exes but what do you what do you say
about her making four repeated mistakes
by not choosing the best options before
proceeding rafael de beise it says your
message was deleted
britt cormier she has three kids when
she opened her legs for the last guy she
knew her situation and was and still had
unprotected sex why are the women saying
he knew and not she knew she is not
mature enough to use birth control um
eddie oh 200 super chat i'm going to
give you a whoo get isha camera
one those those choosing the mom's side
is layman irresponsible two she recorded
the video to embarrass the man who's
showing up to bring food for his child
to think she's right as lame as hell
three to the lady in the middle with the
ugly pants and the pretty face marry me
um wayne williams calling a man a
deadbeat dad for not for not being there
for his kids but but
but a mom kill a baby and call it pro
change tom mcdonald
johnny 17 202. if a man brought food for
just her kids and through then the man
threw a fit
the excuses from some in here would be
hella different hold people fairly
accountable
austin everton a 100 100 um 100 euro
super chat thank you
um ice hall of fame oh gosh i just
clicked okay ice hollow field pearl
you're looking good in black question is
five ten two short for you asking for a
friend um
we i could work with five ten um jay
blasey 215. y'all are getting heated
over a skit here's her ig um miss joy
her baby daddy asked where are their
daddies with an ass at she clearly has
more than two baby daddies rob i could
have told you that by the video robert
um single moms equals a waist mr smith
the woman doubled down on her actions
stop it swoosh baseball addict 365
divided by two equals
182.5 meals y'all would not feel the
same about 183
meals
j blaz 3215. it's a skit look at her ig
it might be
britt cormier she took food for the kid
and threw it on the ground does that not
sound like something a stable person
would do she would rather waste food the
food than letting one of her children
have it jack ballard judging from how
far apart the women's were that woman
was i'm pretty sure her parents were
related i don't think she's playing with
a full deck
j blasey three two one five super chat
jay knapp help me get clarity i hear
men seeking freedom from being bound to
unwanted conceptions financially so will
these same men consent to relinquish
their rights and authority over that son
being altered into a daughter as well
monkey yusop this woman is clearly wrong
if you defend her you are wild she could
cook for her own kid she's got money for
her weave and makeup but not food for
your kids crazy nick the magnificent now
it's the food next it's gonna be school
clothes for them and more why not hold
these other baby daddies accountable
swoosh baseball addict
so i gotta buy
the so i gotta buy all the kids a gift
on my kid's birthday that man is is the
man in the rust is a planet
ellis stare horden pearls there's a
difference between being cheap and
sensible
preston spears he is on child support
because she's got he
he on child support too because she has
to get food stamps the savvy ninja stop
it stop it stop it she didn't get her
food stamps till the 11th but she has
eye eyelashes the size of texas i can't
even jack naf across the country they
doing a little sec
sex strike after they're done these
women finally let us dip in the old
dirty grail asking for a friend okay um
gary grant you realize this is fake sibo
nice you i've seen a bunch of your
videos but i ain't subbed so i guess we
have beef that's true if you guys
haven't seen two or if you've watched
two of my two or more of my videos and
you don't subscribe we do have beef um
okay how about i get a grill for you and
we can eat on a beach with some candles
oh gosh
your name is famous single mothers
aren't looking for love they're looking
for help
spectacularly in
illustrated julius may's pearl is
beautiful thank you mgtow by logic the
guy reacted wrong he should have just
left ate the food and not said a word
then left f this b
men grow out grow a set of nuts for nuts
for christ sakes
let me refresh i think that might be all
of them
um let me just refresh it to make sure
let's see okay
um k vang should he provide closed
school supplies toys and games for other
kids as well um joe theming it's
complicated tim poole has entered the
chat
the original black karen um
five pounds thank you
joseph 713 orange man bad
jc college fund for the poll creator j
minister he didn't do anything wrong
while also doing everything right
everything including emotions nothing
wrong at worst neutral
dc081 can't trust an emotional guy who
paints fingernails hls the beast pearl
you should have a british accent by now
come back to the u.s norwack mother's
likely mother likely is the food
provider guys actions cause pr
predictable problems mother wants to
keep peace in the house damien wade for
the coffee tea fun pearls keep putting
in the work thank you i do i'm trying to
quit coffee so this is day one
because i spilled it today so i couldn't
drink it so you could say i'm going
strong
house house of hats if ish is ugly can
we get a refund
i like that
okay liz sanchez watching and listening
to you from miami keep dropping chris
and making some krispy kreme donuts love
your content pearl thank you so much um
why would you make that your name
um keep the conversations going
no stop it stop it
no no no no no okay
um okay
um okay
johnny17202 pull the group who would pay
for the kid with after their baby mamas
pop out or who would just buy the food
for their own kids
don't agree they're wrong black wolf inc
you cannot have a good faith
conversation with who does not adjust
their views based on statistics
conversation over immediately sleepless
sepny thank you for the super chat
charles martin then it goes to the
negotiation we're arguing what's decent
versus responsibility britt cormier um
okay okay i think that's all of them let
me refresh it one more time do you see
any well any while i was reading the
last couple-ish
let me just see
um
oh gosh there's more okay um the the
original black karen thank you for the
other super chat ruthless pug i'm behind
on this live so this is for earlier in
the show the sheer fact she prioritizes
her nails lips eyebrows and lashes above
feeding her kids is enough to for me to
say that she should use custody j yeah
just want to say the baby girl in green
is so beautiful dumb the savvy ninja
there is no way there is no way they
wrote out this convoy give them an emmy
if this was a skit
and i think that's all of them okay so i
have a question
is it different now that we find out he
comes over every other day to give him
food and it's 183 meals a year
wait
oh hold on we're on meeting everyone
okay
is it different no it's 183 meals i
think i think it's absolutely justifies
him
based on the objectivity of what we've
seen i think it justifies him
and then it's like 300 like 883 even if
it's like five bucks that's still a
couple hundred bucks a year he's doing
something and that's
more than you could say for certain
other five people that have never met
their dad or even present or even wants
to know the child he's doing something
should he bring it because of the whole
time
because of the whole argument is that
he should there's children there and he
should have brought it for all the kids
all them other times should they have
brought them food as well
based on based on your argument though
and should you do christmases birthdays
and arrests because obviously we don't
want to mostly to his kid so surely he
should do that let me throw spanish in
is my mic one i can't yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay let me throw spanners in the
work if he was really about it he would
just buy food that she can cook for the
kids then she has nothing to say but why
should he inconvenience his own child
but he is though because he wants to buy
the best food
he doesn't want to cook he doesn't want
to fund payload it's essentially what
you're saying he should do child support
to fund
wait 183 meals times hold on times let's
say
let's say five dollars which is
that's that's pretty cheap i think it's
gonna be more if it's three other kids
that's nine hundred dollars and that's a
month's rent listen if he buys whole
foods for five dollars for the for the
kid right and the mom chooses to make a
meal out of that five dollars worth of
food yeah because it's more you can get
more food with five dollars than you can
you can get more food with whole foods
with five dollars than the five dollars
format
you've just switched the conversation
all right so now he's funding with the
whole family either way he's funding the
whole family because why is he giving
her resources to use on the other kids
that doesn't make no sense
about that even if even if he made the
food even if he gave the food right
so it was whole foods it's not
mcdonald's because mcdonald's is not
nutritional trash it's trash you're
basically giving your child empty
calories that's not a good decision so
so what she should do is then make food
and then meal
if she's a good mother let's go back to
the argument if she's a good mother
there's nothing to do with being a
mother about him being a father that's
got nothing to do they're not
inherent on each other are they but he's
still providing the food he's still
providing the food the food that we're
arguing about right now him providing
for his child he's providing the food
he gives it to the mother the mother
makes a meal
now she can choose oh i want to give it
some that one child say johnny
or i can share it am i sorry sorry sorry
johnny johnny yeah or
she can make a meal and shut her mouth
because she ain't got nothing she how
can she say no no listen though how can
she say oh you only got food for my one
child
let me let me just understand this so
you think you think so let's say the
mcdonald's meal for one kid is five
dollars yeah so you think he should go
to the store what should he buy with
five dollars for four kids i don't know
listen
that's the mom's responsibility
yeah now if he for example if i'm not
saying i'm just throwing spanners in the
works that's what i'm doing
right he has five dollars he buys some
whole foods he gives it to the mom it's
the mom's responsibility to use her gas
electric or whatever else to make her
child a meal right that's a responsible
mother that's a responsibility
so how is that any different to him
giving her money and her deciding on
whether she wants to use it on the child
or any of the other children that
doesn't make it but if if he gives her
cash he doesn't know that she'll spend
it
and what you're saying with buying the
whole food is essentially not the cash
that's being used
rather than saying that he has to give
her money i'm just saying bring whole
foods but i'm saying so now he has to go
out of his way to go to the ground he's
a good dad though he's a good dad
again no no no no no no no no
no this one's this once again i'm sorry
this once again is integrity versus
obligation yeah he's not obligated
that's all the [ __ ] matters at the
end of the day so he's a good dad and he
thinks by mcdonald's is a good is a good
dad thing to do if it was about i i
agree with you okay let's flip it again
he could cook a meal and bring it for
his son what can she say to that tenant
nothing he can't say nothing she would
have said the same thing the same thing
no but he chose to make that gone
basically what what i think is when it
comes down to
the taking the food where there's
children
this guy didn't do nothing wrong
remember i said that
the woman is completely and wrong again
remember i said that but when it comes
to bringing something where there's
other children around
remove that children from there
christmas it's that simple about that
she didn't let him let him take the job
you're saying now that we know uh-huh
that day every day thing does change so
just remove the child from there i know
she tried
he said let's let me i'll take him in my
car and she said no okay but how do we
know this has been an everyday thing
that he's tried that that's an
assumption again we're not going based
off the objectivity of what we're seeing
let's stick to what we've seen just so
purely what we've seen so based off that
it should remove but that's based off
what she's saying does he talk about the
meals around no no no i'm saying in the
video he said i'll take the kid in the
car and she said no
on that specific day what what does it
mean
what does it mean you just work like i'm
saying i'm saying i'm saying i know
because i'm saying that adds up the
money adds up yes i'm saying rather than
the money adding up let's take the child
okay
anything else anything else is
assumption we don't know what happened
on the other side and i agree but she's
saying based off because no in the video
in though in the video he said he comes
every other day
that's what i'm saying so this is all
based off of the video so i calculated
how many times how many times that how
many meals that is if he's coming every
other day that's 183 meals this is all
based off the video you guys are the one
bringing up up stuff that might not have
happened in the video assumption exactly
what i'm saying what why every other day
but not every day yeah that's irrelevant
that's irrelevant he's bringing his
child food anything other than
anything but what i'm saying is what i'm
saying is rather than bringing food this
i'm listening to what you're saying he's
not obligated to he's not obligated he's
not no one's saying he is i'm giving you
an answer to the question you asked and
the answer was he tried to remove he
tried to take the charge
is an assumption and assumptions don't
matter when objectivity we need to
answer what she said because she just
worked out a whole year based off of the
video exactly based off of the video
what you're saying is is you're saying
it's possible that maybe something else
happened on a different day everything
i'm saying is based off of the video i'm
not talking about previous stages
you just said that's what you just did
you did just talk about previous days
on go talk into the mic ongoing
forget yesterday forget today which is
where he bought the meal
she said if that's going to be a lot of
money throughout the whole year for all
the children he doesn't need to do all
the children we're saying one specific
time he might need to do all the
children but specifically why ongoing
why why should even do i said might i
said might no there's nothing okay we're
not dealing with it's never
i feel like you don't want to listen
sorry but i think
i think i think you're moving the
goalpost yes exactly i think you're just
you're making excuses for the whole
situation that's all you're doing
if there was no obligation and we're
going he has no obligation
he tried to remove his death but
anything else is an assumption anything
else is an assumption we don't know what
happened on another day is he allowed to
move his child going forward
yes or no well if she says no that if
she no no no no no here's what i will
say let me ask you a question right
if he tried to take his job that day i'm
gonna assume based on the way she's been
and based on what i've seen i'm only
going to assume any time he previously
tried to she still would have said no
any time past more videos bro trust me
yeah right but at the end of the day
what's the best predictor of future
behavior
past behavior exactly would you agree
that i'm assuming you that she wouldn't
exactly but i don't give a [ __ ] about
assuming at the end of the day
stick to the objectivity of the video he
turned up and he provided for his child
he has no obligation to any other child
he done his duty and his diligence
that's all that matters at the end of
the day that's all anything else is an
excuse you didn't see it through to the
end
because she slapped the food out of his
hand yeah yeah she slapped it yeah yeah
but he stood there and he stood there i
just thought oh i should have been a man
i just want to talk to the viewers at
home this is an example of how a guy can
do everything right and the world would
still say he did something wrong this is
why this is my show commuter mike you
keep doing this this is this is how this
is an example of how
literally a guy can do everything right
and the world will still make excuses
they'll still make that's all i'm
arguing can i ask you a question
who out of all of us who said the guy
has done anything wrong you just said
the whole this whole time you've been
arguing you and that's why that's why i
know you're not listening no you said he
done 90 right but
i'm wrong
i'm saying yeah and i said the ten
percent is that still wrong
it's the off chance i'm just talking
about based off off chance i'm saying if
anything the woman is complete how many
some of us sat here and said the woman
is completely wrong i've agreed with you
yeah and i've said that but then you'll
say but and then make an excuse so you
can say that but if you add a butt
there's two
previously exactly imagine someone
apologized to you and said but i'm sorry
i'm sorry i [ __ ] your sister but she
was fit thing is the thing is the thing
is
there's two sides to the coin
that's all i'm trying to show you here
i'm trying to show you the same way the
woman is responsible for her [ __ ]
behavior is also the same way the man
could have handled it better that's what
i'm saying and all i'm arguing is that
he'd done everything he needed to she
was completely in the wrong he was
completely in the right from what we see
from from the video that we see and
that's ultimately all that matters okay
my questions
my question to you is obviously you said
about the
the correct decorum to handle in terms
of children but we never asked what
about christmas because basically
based on christmas you wouldn't want him
to be alienated but say she's broke she
can't even get food stamps he comes and
does a mad thing what she does do she do
it for the rest of the day where do we
draw the line where are we drawing
necessarily because where are we drawing
the lines you're saying how should he
handle that differently everywhere
where's the line who wants
everyone's christmas gift
generally is very different they hold
different values right
let's go back to his original mum all
right let's go let's go
yeah that's great based on his question
right
does he is he obligated to give you any
other chance i've agreed with you
and that's why you're not listening okay
okay you're saying principally he should
bring food yeah so rather than not a
hundred times over a hundred i said
first of all he can remove the child you
said that time he tried to and i said he
needs to handle it he could handle it a
little bit differently so how should he
handle christmas different should he buy
presents as well just but everyone's
present holds a different way i just
said that and if he's not obligated to
what matters past that point if he's not
obligated to what matters past that
point it's a discussion no no no no
that's a discussion yeah that's fine but
this discussion your discussion is
purely based on emotion that's fair
that's all i've been arguing this whole
time it's purely based on emotion what
you would like to be the case and i'm
not going to lie to you i actually agree
in an ideal world i'd like to see that
myself but that's not the reality of
what we see and that's not the reality
of what we see on that video but who can
i ask a question who assigns uh is my
mind oh yeah
who assigns obligation you need to put
your headphones on oh i've got yeah i've
got one on that's right yeah
who i don't know
who's assigning okay in this
situation a little bit here's how i can
here's how i kind of put this way i'll
comment this a different way here's how
i can
no but answer just answer that straight
question who assigns obligation in this
situation okay i'll answer it with a
question
if he proves no no this is my answer
though
it's with a question right if he brings
his child gifts and is not obligated to
would you agree that he's not in the
would you agree that he's not in the
wrong by doing that yeah there's the
obligation exactly
it's okay to do that yeah
he's okay to do that it goes back to the
point where you just asked him what
would he do over christmas and he's been
trying to say remove him from the city
situation and take him where if he's got
his house or whatever take him away from
the situation but i know then you not
might fight back and say well if the
mom's not letting him then right but
based on the video she didn't so we can
assume that prior to that and post that
she wouldn't even
assumption it is
i am agreeing with you here my
assumption that pre or any situation
outside of what we see in the video is
an assumption i agree i'm saying that
myself what i am saying is none of that
actually matters outside of what we see
in the video and like paul said anything
prior to that if you're gonna if you're
gonna assume right this is sorry this is
what we've seen in the video naturally
you are going to say right if i'm going
to if i'm going to put any money down
i'm going to say that previously she
didn't let him and after this situation
with him tell me that you don't believe
that tell me that you wouldn't agree
that that's likely the thing is i don't
know why we keep going down this
conversation over here it's an
assumption so let's stick to the video
what we do let me let me learn uh i
don't
see why we keep going down the
conversation of he could have handled it
differently by taking the truth
doesn't matter that's courtesy if he if
he had to pay child support say 500
pound and all the kids were broke and he
went up to mum and he slapped 500 pounds
in front of their kids yes it's a
prickish thing to do but he's not
obligated to hide the money that he's
given he can do whatever the [ __ ] he
likes as long as legally he does what
his obligation all the rest is emotional
courtesy and what you think is
subjectively right exactly
as you said he can do what he likes
right and she's doing what she likes is
that not the same by harassing him
that is at the cost of her kids yeah
exactly so what the [ __ ] does that even
mean
listen to what listen to the what i'm
trying to say so basically she's doing
what she wants for clout right we
understand that we agree with that she's
been irresponsible
irresponsible et cetera et cetera he
wants to bring food for his child she's
not feeling it because that's her
position you should have brought
food for all of my kids right he's not
obligated to do it right we said there's
integral parts of this where he could
have provided for the other children
just out of curtis which doesn't matter
yeah which doesn't matter to you guys
right so why don't that [ __ ] make a
[ __ ] meal for the other three kids
well clearly she doesn't have the means
to do so then stop sleeping around and
don't worry why do you have a weave it's
200 bucks steven getaway
like i said what do you mean yeah
there's evidence she does she has money
enough money to buy the weave the lashes
and the nails as we've discussed
do you think it cost more than five
dollars do you think it costs more than
five dollars
the weave the lashes and the nails do
you think she spent more than five
dollars
okay okay so let's get it let's go let's
get real if she's paying out of her own
pocket which maybe she's not let's be
real we don't know if she got sugar
daddy free baby daddies blah blah we got
this is the reality this is the we're
talking about where
we're we're looking at this woman in a
negative light because that is the truth
right in this situation
yeah
this is what we're saying right
so she's got multiple baby daddies yeah
and she they could potentially be paying
her giving her money to to for her to
fulfill her lifestyle choices yeah
you're looking for an exception
it's not an exception
can we say that her reaction
was
based off the fact that she
she feels as if like
if he's bringing food for one child in
terms of just like
how the other kids would feel
because of it can we say that's that was
the reaction not necessarily because
it's just like the because we know what
kids are like right so can we say that's
fair can we say that her reaction was
based off like oh my children the up the
wrestling we're going to see this nope
because she because she could she could
have done that without filming it oh 100
and i agree no no no no but i'm saying
no no so that's when it comes back no no
so i would say no and the reason i would
say no it wasn't based off of her kids
is because if she was thinking about her
kid she wouldn't have filmed it she was
thinking about me me me and to be fair
to to agree with you speaking to the mic
speaking to agree with them on that
point she would have just said go in the
car when he offered to take the kid and
i'll bring the child out
so to me that's an entitlement she wants
the money she doesn't want to pay for it
100 and we we all agree with that that's
the matter
i'm not like all i'm hearing at this
point is we all agree with me and pearl
and anything else isn't it is an
extension of an excuse and an emotion
i'm not like that is literally all i'm
rounding this up into but when it comes
to discussion like you lot can't remove
emotions i don't i don't i don't see why
people think you can remove emotion from
me i actually agree with that no no i
actually agree i actually agree that we
should be sensitive to emotions but in
this situation we can own a lawyer is
only gonna go off the objectivity of the
information he has he has to remain
objective he has to remain strictly
fact-minded right and that's all we're
doing we have the evidence the evidence
is the two videos we have
i don't even need to go through it
okay so so so so i have i have another
question i haven't i haven't we're gonna
move on
because i just think we're beating a
dead horse at this point so
um we're kind of going into like
father's rights a little bit right and
this is we talked a little bit about
that so if women have the right
to choose an abortion
do you think that men
do you think that men should have the
right to choose a financial abortion yes
or no
i've got to hear this what do you mean
by that so okay so so if i if i get
pregnant right let's let's say you know
i get pregnant and i say i don't want to
be a mother right i can have an abortion
and i don't have to be a mother
does a man if he gets me pregnant he
says you know what i don't want to be a
father can he have a financial abortion
where he will sign off his rights and he
does not owe any child support or have
to have anything to do with that child
so go ahead
you [ __ ] know my answer
yeah okay yeah i don't see why it'd be
any different to when a sperm donor
signs a non uh non non waiver that he
has no obligation
yeah i agree because if you've said no i
don't want to have this child then and
that woman has agreed to yeah she's
going to carry it then that's on her no
yeah i agree with that as well hundred
percent i agree her body her choice
er with but his money his choice you
agree can you speak into the microwave
sorry thank you oh
sorry this has moved like a bit higher
than it was before no i'm so you moved
it up you see i might move it like tilt
it
this way no now you gotta move it down
and tilt it up
it's fine just tilt it towards you yeah
yeah yeah so it's facing you okay okay
yeah go ahead yeah so
his money his choice her body her choice
yeah yeah but when it comes to the
initial act of having sex with a woman
and you put your sperm inside a woman
you've already signed the fact that
you're going to be responsible whatever
the outcome is okay
let me ask you a quick question so wait
so i just just follow just to clarify
you said his money his choice 100 so you
do think he should be able to sign and
have a financial abortion 100 percent
okay so do we
yeah we want to stream
i still have i still have that but which
is very key to the point in terms of if
you sleep with a woman and you put your
sperm inside her you've you've signed
your responsibility
initially that's what i believe but
hardline can you still get a financial
abortion
hard line can you still get a financial
abortion irrespective of that point
this is where you need to put things
into scenarios and perspectives no i'm
saying let's put this let's put let's
put this another way right
if he straps up and [ __ ] happens
does he still have that right
the right to opt out oh hundred percent
because because because hundred percent
because i could i could
[Laughter]
i can tell you from just logic and
experience i'm sure everybody listening
to this can
if a man doesn't want to have a child he
will go through it it will strap up
he'll take every measure and he will
make sure that she takes every measure
flex yeah
and i agree with that yeah but what i'm
saying is so if he was irresponsible do
you think he should not have the right
to a financial abortion
it would be it'll be harder for him to
it should be harder for him to because
he's he's showed the responsibility in
the first place
yeah he still can though so you would
say he can't is it because i you're not
really giving me a yes or no answer and
i'm good i don't think it's
straightforward that's the reason why
but here's the thing the law is
straightforward so if there was to be a
law passed it would be black and white
it wouldn't be so in other words if at
any point during the pregnancy whether
it was planned or unplanned she can opt
out should he whether it was planned or
unplanned be able to opt out of 18 years
of child support to summarize to balance
out the skills yeah of course that's all
that's awesome yeah so did we agree
um just so you guys know we did do a
poll in the chat and 93 said they would
just pay for their own child if anyone
was curious
okay someone someone gave a five dollar
super chat to ask pearl ask all the
people present do they control their
emotions or do your emotions control you
i absolutely control my emotions no
doubt
yeah i can i'd say do you know what what
100 of the time you control your
emotions
i think i think most people that think
that they're logical don't control their
emotions personally i think they hide
from their emotions i think there's no
way i think there's no way to prove that
but that's what i think
because i'm as you can all tell quite an
emotional guy but i can control my
emotions
whether you believe that or not yeah
generally
no generally speaking i think it it can
sort of like
prove
that the type of man or the type of
woman you are
based on the decisions you make are you
likely or are you someone who generally
speaking acts out of emotion or you're
someone who acts out of logic
and that's based on each situation
okay yeah i think it depends i'm not
going to sit up and say 100 percent like
i think it's a bit of both like it
depends i'm not gonna
like something someone wouldn't make me
act crazy out of character where i lose
my [ __ ] and start doing crazy things
like clean up a man's car or something
mad like that that's not what i'm gonna
do but something
i'm thinking like even on a small scale
someone could irritate me
and i
cursed him out or something like he's
acting off emotion so i'm not going to
sit and say i'm not going to i don't
actually actually do you know what yeah
based on that point i agree that based
on a point i think it's actually worth
noting that it depends on the extension
of what the result is as what's as a
result of the emotion i think that's
worth the stuff people piss you off but
you're not always going to see your zen
i'm just going to be like
i'll meditate and come back
and we all have bad days yeah exactly
yeah
i just don't whack out and phone and
film someone when i am
neither do we but a lot of people do it
no day and age we're in now but like you
go you see the most and you're just like
why are you even doing this but it's day
and age we're living now like everything
has to get filmed i just don't think
that's a good excuse it's not a good
excuse and i don't think it's an excuse
for anyone that does it i just think
people need to learn to be more private
everything's going on the internet these
days for and people are looking for
people's answers in the comments it's
just like build your own [ __ ] yourself i
agree it's a sad reality but it is the
reality it's it's frustrating it is
because i don't want to live in that
country i have another question why do
you think we have a generation of
entitled women
boy
i think women
women have always been told
and this isn't a lot and just to make a
preface this doesn't mean all women
right it doesn't mean i know a lot of
really great women that aren't entitled
and but we we have to admit there is a
modern women woman that we are seeing
that is very entitled that brings
nothing to the table and expects
everything in return
so so where did this come from
i believe like
a lot of people have been told
especially millennial and generations
generation is that we're very special i
think in utopia realist they did a
survey on the u.s society and in the
1930s only 20 of the people thought they
were special where they did it in the
early 2000s and 90 percent of people
thought they did
so people actually think they're
relevant especially especially for women
for when they do things that have bad
outcomes like for example will gain ton
of weight they'll be support group to
lift them up
shout out to lizzo
when it comes to a man if say if you're
a five foot five man you're fat and
you're broke and you've got a miffy
hairline
people will tell you you are not
valuable to society my friend where's a
woman who's fat someone will come to
love you true and someone will [ __ ] you
mm-hmm
can i cut down to men cannot just can i
just stress i actually touched on this
yesterday in yesterday's podcast please
go back and watch that because i think i
pretty much ended that argument that at
the end of the day for women
in that sense you literally only need
your looks initially and past that
loyalty
i don't really feel like anything past
that is actually valuable for a man he
needs to offer far more he needs to
prove far more he needs to demonstrate
far more it goes beyond your looks and i
absolutely think because of that society
has played into that and as a result it
is a it's a femme centric society can i
just add to it so i do agree that women
do have the upper hand in that respect
the factors that i would consider in
this scenario are one a lot of women are
growing up without fathers they don't
have male direction growing up so they
don't know how to operate with men in
their household um another thing is
a lot of women are given opportunity to
feel extraordinary when they haven't
done much they haven't they haven't even
i agree no no honestly like you know as
a you know back in not so long ago you
had to have certain faculties about you
to be a good woman now it's about
superficial
and this online identity we also let me
cut because i could talk forever on this
subject feminism key key key factor
giving women ultimate power where they
shouldn't have it it shouldn't you know
there's certain areas that are
well in my opinion should be exclusively
for men and it's become well if men do
it we can and that shouldn't be the case
so men don't want to play netball i'm
just saying that
for that for men but there isn't a name
so just to finish up i'll just close it
down men are also no no it's all right
men have also been emasculated in the
process
like really emasculated to the point
where they
they start to move a bit feminine in
their ways
and they start to respond in a
non-logical direction so for me growing
up with a lot of men in my family
i always saw purpose-driven
decision-making a lot of but now they
don't have decision-making skills
because they're not allowed to make
decisions women make them for
the men do you know what i 100 agree
with that you actually agree with me
it's not that i agree it's 100 percent
agree with you oh 100
and i will even add to it and say that
yes men are becoming emasculated in the
process which is one thing right but the
fact that men
actually choose to opt for an very very
feminine lifestyle is absolutely on the
men it's nobody else's fault the social
conditioning can be there but i believe
as men we are objective we are logical
naturally biologically and as a result
that is the fault of the men 100. i
think a lot of this problem comes down
to the simpy men because a lot of the
simply men
a lot of these women with these bad
behaviors they support her and gassed
them up for every fat influencer there's
about a thousand simply men television
can i hear from you too
i just wanted to say basically um
i was watching a video the other day and
the guy was basically explaining that i
feel like and it's not like i'm blaming
men and it's none of that at all but the
standards
you don't tell a woman this that that
that you let her do what she's gonna do
and say she wants this and she wants
that but you don't ask her what she's
bringing to your table you don't you
don't ask her what she's bringing to
your table and you need to ask her what
she's bringing to your table if you've
got certain standards some men they just
again it's the whole social media
whatever looks oh she's pretty she's
that and i just want to get in there and
do it that's why i said no do you know
how a woman comes to a man and says what
do you bring to my table what do you do
and all of that stuff they need to be
asking 100 i have styles for it
if a man says i want you to cook good
you're a misogynist now yeah and you
know what again again i 100 agree i've
always said am i missing sitting over
there she's going to test this right
this is before we got together right i
always said that women have a list of
criteria that as a man you must fulfill
men you need to stand up and actually
opt so you need to build your own list
of criteria
absolutely it absolutely helps you out i
want you to speak up i'm sorry because
we have this kind of discussions all the
time yeah about gender roles and stuff
so i want you to talk talk your talk say
your piece
yeah go ahead god it's the time to do it
um
you're wrong
i was waiting for that
um so i do agree
with that to some extent so i do believe
that um society has become
more feminine
however
there's like a whole other side of it so
there are pros to that so with
men becoming a little bit more emotional
i feel like sometimes that allows for
emotional understanding of your partner
that's a pro
i hear that but when he comes crying to
you because he's he can't brush his hair
you're going to call him a [ __ ] in it
that's a big streamer
exactly how you'd say it when we discuss
it
talk about gender roles because all of
it no but i don't feel like gender roles
apply in this conversation because
i i agree with what everyone's saying i
do agree that society has become
a little bit more feminine however
doesn't mean that there's not masculine
males out there and
they're still always going when you have
an alpha male he's an alpha male
regardless doesn't matter how many women
are around him or
what society brings to him and i think
that just shines anyway whereas you
might have someone who's
more feminine i'm not going to say beta
so i just think it's deep
um what do you think is true
but
that's just i don't know i feel like
there's pros and cons to being masculine
and feminine it's like the the whole
argument about an alpha male
is like the and the fake alpha males so
you have like an alpha male who is
naturally a leader and a provider but
then there's other
aspects of alpha male which is like
misogyny can i just quickly say
something because i i mean i fully agree
i think generally speaking now we assume
that to be an alpha male you need to be
the bad boy yeah
yeah yeah yeah and the bad boy traits
okay so
men
men take on this i'm an alpha she views
me as a bad boy and they do play on it
right and it does become very extensive
in a negative way however
i truly believe that when women say they
want a bad boy because you're the ones
who use the word not us right when women
say they want a bad boy what you're
actually saying is you want a man who
exhibits all of the traits actually just
making the dom make him a dominant
masculine male yeah and yeah i i do but
let me let me quickly ask a question
though i do agree that men are becoming
more emotional and you're saying it can
work
it can be kind of our bonus right if a
man was to come to you with a sop story
and be emotional how would you respond
personally
see for me it wouldn't be an issue
because i feel like if if someone's
generally upset and that's your partner
you should be able to listen okay about
about about little things
[Music]
because that's what we see
it really hurt my feelings and i really
want you to hear what i'm going through
because like that really my lens doesn't
have a cap anymore are you are you are
you more attracted to ish now
okay let me give you an example let me
give you an example if he comes home if
he comes home every single night
or
several nights throughout the week and
he just complains about how his job's
making him feel [ __ ] and he's not
yeah i was just gonna say i don't think
that's not
for me that's not um i would be like
okay let you need to start thinking
about like what's going on in your life
why are you feeling that way and then
let's figure this out you see that's why
it's confusing for men because every
line is different for girls right
because some girls like have a low
tolerance for that some have a high
right maybe yours is higher than most
girls but like you're still a woman and
at some point you're going to get
repulsed by it at some point and how is
he supposed to know what point that is
so a lot of men just would rather error
on the side of i don't want to lose i
don't want to lose the girl yeah yeah
yeah yeah anyway and i just wanted to
add to your point what is what defines
masculinity so
you know this whole thing about
this generation they're defining
masculinity as something totally
different
to previous generations as i said for me
masculinity is a man who can make
logical decisions decision making is a
key masculine skill yeah i agree and
yeah that's one of them yeah yeah one of
them exactly and and
when you strip that away from a man
you're stripping away his purpose when
you strip away a man's purpose you're
stripping him off his masculinity of his
identity exactly identity exactly so
we're all agreeing i like you i like you
yeah
i would like to add just the last bit
because i've been talking a lot today
but when you strip away that masculinity
as a woman you're more likely to step
into a masculine role
and that's where you get this kind of
dynamics
and then you get bored of it you're like
you're like hang on a minute [ __ ]
but that's why the feminists confuse men
because they're like oh we want you to
be more emotionally available have you
ever noticed how feminists only advocate
for men when it benefits them because
they want them to be more emotionally
available well
they want to be dominant
friend zone is a great example of that
the problem with for me for me the
problem with emotional availability
defined by a woman means that you're
making a man feminine because the
emotions you're seeking i know you're
gonna find to validate your feelings to
validate you
men
in my experience and my understanding
and you know like my dad or whatever
they channel their emotions so
differently and because we don't really
we can say we do but we don't really
understand it we don't
meet men of that same level that's just
how it is we're different yeah but it
comes down to a part of us as humans and
different sexes we advocate for things
that we don't necessarily want now
you'll get some ugly ugly guy men do it
do too you'll be like ah i want to get
all this money so i can attract the
baddest chick but then when they want
the baddest chick they want ah i want
her to like me not for my money yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i was wrong in the way you went
about it in the first point you said let
me get all this money so i can get so
what do you expect when she's all around
for the month
for me that would feed into his own
insecurity in the first place yeah i
agree with that i grew up you are a man
within yourself yeah like within
yourself you know that you have the
faculties to get any woman you want a
man who has to use
um use
materialism to get women can't get women
he's not a man there's an astronaut
he knows within himself that he doesn't
have the faculties to actually
uh get that guy wrong yeah again whether
you say that but someone like jay-z who
i respect so much you think you'd have
beyonce if you didn't have peace but
you're a jay-z
but jay-z has a certain level of
confidence along with that because given
his status
yeah but because of that he's actually
ran through so many women that's where
the confidence comes from it's actually
not the money that's but it's derived
from the money and status without it as
a starting point because it initially
gives you some confidence but just
just a little view into this world just
as an example now for those who i don't
know i've spoke to a couple people i i
used to be a dating coach right and
there would be many many times i would
have multi-millionaire ceos crying at
the table and these men couldn't pull a
damn [ __ ] in a tug of war
if they tried their hardest because
they are relying i'm sorry but they are
relying on the money and the status of
their career and to
unintentionally go into a separate point
i actually am a true true believer based
on that based on my experience and based
on the experience of men i see in my
life
money and finances they are important as
time goes on with regards to provision
they are not they are not as important
as society makes out and when i say that
what i mean is when women believe that
finances are the ultimate and when men
believe that getting their finances
right at the ultimate i can honestly
attest to this in from various different
aspects of my my life and what i've seen
in my experiences
you can try your absolute hardest
but going back to what you previously
now fully agree with you right
there are certain masculine traits as a
man
higher value traits as a man that you
actually need
being a good decision maker is one of
them being pre-selected is absolutely
one of them there's no negotiating on
that point being a protective male being
a competent male is one of them and
being someone who's actually so damn
confident that he's actually willing to
go out there against
any
any any force resisting him he's so damn
ambitious he's so damn driven that he's
willing to try and fight that and go
after what he wants i truly believe
on a core dna level if you can
demonstrate those traits over and over
again and as time goes on you're with a
woman she can actually see this is just
who you are as a man i truly believe at
the very least you don't even need
finances in check i believe because she
will view you as someone who will get
there because you have the potential and
like i said with with the lack of those
innate traits those internal traits as a
man which you do need
the money and the finances they're
important as time goes on sorry to
reiterate but they're not as important
as society makes that ultimately
i have a question for the girls would
you take a guy that's making
i'm trying to think of the equivalent in
the c 50 us dollars is like what the
exchange rate is 1.22 if that helps you
so let's say a guy that's making like 40
40 thousand pounds is that like average
forty thousand is that average hundred
percent
in the uk
30 k is the average in the uk okay let's
say he's making 35 so slightly above
average
um but you're really attracted to him
and he has like that confidence that
you're talking about or a guy that
you're less attracted to but he makes uh
let's say six figures who would you pick
35k 35k no no questions
no i mean one at a time sorry i'm trying
to get camera angles okay i'd say 35k
because i feel like if you go for the
higher percentage you're not attracted
to him and you're kind of only going
into it for the novelty yeah it's going
to wear off eventually you're going to
be like
this guy's not for me i'm not into him
so
the
like the intimacy is not going to be
there and you can only fake it for so
long until like what you're doing yeah
you're just literally fake 100
the persona the persona
i can't fake nothing that's not getting
faked 35k all day every day because them
six figures eight moving me i don't even
i don't let me put this another way let
me put this another way if i was a woman
you're out with your man i don't care
how long you've been with him he makes
big bank
and he's respected in his career
if you're walking along another man
looks at me in the eyes what the [ __ ]
you looking at and your man shivers and
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you going to
go i'm not i'm sorry no no
honestly if you are you gonna go home
and think
slide inside me
for me for me the 35k makes sense
because
you know sometimes when a man
he
works for
or let me say again when he maintains a
certain standard so only even if it's
only 35k there's other aspects of that
man
that are being maintained
and that is all that really matters and
girls and girls will buy into a guy's
future but you have to like
like the device yeah yeah but you have
to like because a girl will date a guy
that's dead broke because she believes
he won't be forever i mean
i don't think i don't i don't think most
girls will stay with a bum forever yeah
i think i think if he's if if he's going
nowhere they're going to be out that's
limited like you have to have some sort
of money right but but a girl
but i think a girl will put up with a
like i don't want to say put up with but
she won't require as much if you can
convince her that you're going somewhere
and you're on a train and this is where
you're headed she'll stick by you yeah
if she can see that you are a safe bit
and that you have potential and i think
men being visionaries in what they're
deciding so back to making decisions if
you can show a woman that you can make
solid decisions even if you make
mistakes
you make solid decisions you stick by
what you were doing you can show
solvency to some respect like some
respect i think that makes sense and you
can show that you know what i will
protect you
i do know how to love you i know how to
be intimate with you
these things all add up together whereas
with the finances you could buy a bag
this guy you could lose your job
tomorrow yeah yeah and also
the guy with 35k could buy you a lesser
bag but it's actually the fault behind
it
and the the way he's managed his money
just to put that in your hands
you know appreciate your position
because kevin samuels used to call them
hive kevin summers used to call them
high value men in training so like if
you if you're not a seven or eight or
nine say you're an adjustable five or
six you need to grab someone who before
he quite gets to that you need to catch
him in training i'm saying yeah it's
just like how certain a man will see an
ugly duckling you're like if i take you
weight watchers and you lose two stones
oh there's someone has another question
they say they don't they don't buy it
they say 100 bs don't stop at 100k pearl
up it to 250k and you get to travel and
the 35k guy is on his own so the second
guy is 250k and you get to travel but
like i'm gonna do a caveat 35k is making
that money the rest of his life it's
never going to get better
well i'm in love with the man you know
as i said
yeah yeah for me i've seen it firsthand
you know
from my family where the finances
weren't always top tier but they but the
love and the compassion and the
direction as like my grandfather giving
the family direction had more weight
than money there were people around him
with more money than him wouldn't have
the weight that's a good point like
jordan peterson actually talks about he
actually says in
in
within families
the man reaches a cap with regards to
how much he can earn past that point
anything is
it's obsolete you earn a certain amount
of money right and to touch on the point
that people just made right
so to send it up that
that asks this question okay so he's
earning 250k a year versus the man who's
earning for example 50k right yeah if
the man who was earning 250k a year
could spoil you with yacht trips
uh flights to dubai you can have
basically you can have everything at
your feet right yeah but if that man
wasn't respected by anybody he had no
drive outside of the money because he
could have been a lotto winner right and
also
if he wasn't actually wanted by any
other women however the 50k one was a
ladies man other women wanted him but he
was still choosing you he was still very
driven and he had the ambition to keep
moving forward he had people around him
that he led even if he made mistakes
even if he was wrong but he was a leader
right yeah
which one now based on that because you
you always have to you have to include
all of it right which one now would you
choose well you what you're just i'll
let you answer the question what you're
describing there is competition anxiety
see us as men generally speaking no
matter what whoever likes the woman that
we're looking at if she's ugly she's
ugly but you see as women they're driven
by they like to be with the guy that's
the guy yep so from whenever they see
him being the guy and other people
respect him automatically there
there's water flowing
in between and i can tell and i can tell
you from experience
it's not to say that he can't have money
yeah he can have money
but without those traits you're doomed
yeah that's what i for my personal
business
yeah get the [ __ ] out and you'll just be
upset for no reason
why are you blinking this way
can i just say all of the points that i
just made so he is a leader of men yeah
he's pre-selected he is protective well
let's just use those three as a basis
right a foundation that's very
attractive it's very attractive and
and just to extend on that
they are
they are biological yeah they are
hardwired into you through evolution
read the read the mystery method he goes
into this is actually based all of his
for those who don't know mystery method
pickup artist he's this is what he bases
all of his
um
success on is the evolutionary
evolutionary psychology is that if
you're a man who is a leader you you're
i.e a decision-maker you can protect and
provide or you've got that protective
nature right you're looking for a man
who is willing to step in and protect
you even if he couldn't the fact that he
had that innate ability i'm gonna
protect you right that's going to say
something on a dna level right and then
i think
honestly i could actually argue this is
number one if he's pre-selected if other
women want him if other women like him
if he has a history of sleeping around
you are on a dna honestly you're on a
dna level you're gonna look at that man
and go he's the [ __ ] man you don't
even have to actually ask how much he
makes just yet firstly you'll see those
things and go he's already the man
anything on top of that the finances in
the career they are a bonus they amplify
you know an interesting stat so the
reason that women say things like men or
trash men are the problem men cheat
is because we're all sleeping with the
same ones
yeah so so the thing is that 20 if you
ask 100 of men what are 100 of women
what they want in a guy they'll list 20
of men sometimes less
yeah so for example if you want a guy
that's over six foot that's 15 percent
of guys
let's say you say i want a guy that's
over six foot and attractive what
percent of men are really attractive so
let's let's cut that in half no just in
general no i'm just saying in general
half of people are you guys are you guys
i'm six foot i'm good
let's just be honest like half of people
are below average so let's say you want
to get this above average and
attractiveness and over six foot right
that cuts it cut that in half
then let's say you want them to make
over let's say you want them to make
them above average income that cut that
in half well then you're gonna you're
looking at like five five percent
ethnicity as well i just wanted to say
this as well everything you listed are
super they're all super visual values
therefore they don't really hold weight
really they're really realistic
one at a time
they hold weight they hold weight
because if you ask women what they want
that's what they list yeah but that's
because of the
that's because of their mindset and this
is why they picked the wrong men because
they released
but this is this is what this is
oh
honestly this is why
women make poor decisions when it comes
to men and we have this woman here with
three four children with multiple men
because her
her choice making is based on
superficial values that are not they
don't produce tangible results in real
terms so when you're looking at a man
and you see the way he carries himself
the way he directs his energy the way he
lives as i said already he lives with
purpose and drives for his family or
whatever
this is these are factors that i would
look at
yeah as women i mean we can all attest
there's there can be a guy you are so
attracted to and then he opens his mouth
and he goes away so fast
he could be like so good-looking
looks attractive but as soon as he opens
up yeah i've never heard him talk yeah
high-pitched voice
speaks too quick and he just rambles on
about [ __ ]
that's basically it's a sunrise
um
i've got another question also
who is it like the is it the roommates
or the housemates i don't know what
their roommate's podcast
um
after like when they asked women what
their criteria was for men versus what
when they asked men it was like men was
like
um a good body
um someone who's loyal someone cook
someone who yeah someone that can cook
someone who they have a good time with
and obviously someone who's getting
better i think i can see some women
women were like
a list yeah yeah that's normal right but
i honestly think i could sum this up for
every man watching
she is not a fat piece of [ __ ] right she
is submissive she is feminine
and she is cooperative and fi and and
ultimately for the men watching
she's loyal
if you can hear oh
sorry sir george repeat that so she can
hear it all those all those things why
are you coming for me no i'll repeat it
okay so encore she's not a fat [ __ ]
she's feminine
she is submissive amen she is
cooperative
and she's loyal wonderful honestly
anything past that
we don't even see
can i can i throw a spanner in the works
we've got got one and just because why
not why not what about the guys who
want a dominant woman and [ __ ]
these are sex deprived simp men who
these are sex deprived men who have
bought into the feminine [ __ ] liar
society okay this is something i've just
noticed there is a group of men that
somewhat like prefers women that are
mean to them yeah yeah and i never and i
i know what you're talking i never
really understood it but until i made
the connection one day a lot of those
guys were raised in single mother
households where the mother wasn't nice
to them and so i thought they used it
yeah like i think that's that's just
what i've noticed like the guys that
tend to prefer it like had a mom that
maybe wasn't the most responsible or
maybe ex
exhibited some of those traits without
the daughter so they have mommy issues
they have mummy yeah that's what just
like the same way like when girls keep
picking like bad guys and you're like
why but a lot of times they didn't have
a dad in the picture
can i ask a question yeah so you know
like how we we always focus on like the
women's side the financial side and
whatnot
and the points that you just mentioned
um about what
men want in a woman
does finances ever come into it do you
think and to a point where not saying
she has to make more than you but what
if she's just someone that's bad with
money like that or she doesn't strive to
want to do anything like where does that
come into it for men couldn't give a
[ __ ] that's that's him i wouldn't i'd
say the main thing that men ask for is
that you should be able to look after
yourself and you should be financially
responsible like not he's not taking a
bag of debt yeah i mean if you're if
you're just accruing debt by spending
irresponsibly and you're pretty much
just an idiot right that's that's a
different story but if you're a woman
who's making minimum wage working at uh
costco or sainsbury's yeah you don't
care don't care and a good example a
good example if you speak
all foreign if she exhibits all of what
i just previously said if she was a
minimum wage worker at tesco
but she held all of the traits the
femininity the loyalty the
submissiveness the beauty i'm talking
top tempe top tier beauty
let me ask you a question why is your
why you as a man why are you looking at
a woman for finances i'm not looking at
her finances i'm just looking at her to
just have her [ __ ] together that's all
it is she can have a [ __ ] together by
having a job and not being an idiot in
life but that's ultimately not what
you're looking at because you need to
you need to i feel like people need to
meet themselves
sorry i feel like people need to meet
themselves whether that goes against
every single biological standard known
to man not not necessarily a good
example of this cristiano ronaldo this
was pointed out recently on the podcast
cristiano ronaldo he picked up a woman
who worked in gucci on minimum wage but
she was a drop dead 10. do you think he
gave a [ __ ] what managed you know
there you go there's there's always
another reason why like these people
pick these people what i'm trying to say
is it's true though isn't it it's true
if you say to me someone that's working
at tesco getting a minimum wage
like
what's like i'm just gonna feel like
what if she's at university are
i'll put it another way right if you met
a woman on a night out she was i'm
talking drop dead gorgeous right
model caliber
she was submissive
what does submissive mean by the way why
why is submissive i'll tell you what
i'll def i'll define this in the
simplest way possible i'm not saying
submissive as in
bow down and yeah and pray to your man
as he walks in the room no no submissive
means
letting your man
take the lead take the lead project his
masculine traits without basically
trying to take over i'll give you i'll
give you an example so for the girls if
you're if you were going out right and
your boyfriend or your husband said to
you i could you change your outfit
that's too revealing would you do it
well he would never have to say that to
me i know that no just i mean maybe
hypothetically hypothetically yeah
because it's your general respect okay
there's a reason why he said it what
about you oh
i feel iffy about it you know if you're
dignitized you're doing it
you're still got time to change your
mind
do you know what i feel like it depends
if i'm wearing if i'm just wearing like
this and he's like that's too revealing
i'd be like hold on a minute that's
never happens
if it's ultimately revealing to the
point it's obvious why the [ __ ] are you
going out wearing that at any time of
the day but i wouldn't yeah i wouldn't
be wearing it anyway do you know what i
mean yeah what if you you don't ever
wear like a short skirt what if you just
thought yeah okay yeah like no i'm just
saying like
most girls have a shorter skirt shorter
dress if he said it's too short can you
change would you do it if it was two if
i looked at if i looked at my booty and
i and i could see cheeks then yeah what
if you disagreed then i'd have to have a
conversation about it but see that's
that's that's not submissive so because
submissive would say
that yes straight away yeah the
submissive is saying to the guy like i
trust you it doesn't mean every guy gets
this power right some guys don't deserve
it because they're not they're not good
leaders but it's basically saying that i
trust this guy to lead and when we don't
know the decision or we're disagreeing
like i'm letting him take the lead and
in that very situation
it's it's important for women to
understand that men in that situation
barely ever are they actually jealous
but we are territorial yeah okay i'm
sorry i like that yeah that's right
but then if you are a truly submissive
woman you would pretty much just bend to
his will okay go ahead i agree i agree
but um at what point
does it become controlling yeah
don't there aren't controlling guys like
that's why i say you don't give that to
every guy where you just follow his like
i had a guy that emailed me when i said
i trust men to make a lot of decisions
because they're a little more logical
like when it comes to my business and
he's like i'm a man well i can make
decisions for you i'm like not anyone
not you
but um but the point is like you find a
trusted man that you trust to lead you
and so a lot of times girls we kind of
get enamored with like you know the bad
boys or maybe like a guy who's a smooth
talker charismatic whatever so a lot of
times like it's helpful to have men that
the guys you're dating like that you
trust so maybe like a father figure or
because
guys can through see through guys
[ __ ] faster than we can so do you
think that sorry
i'll let you go yeah um do you think
so obviously going back to what you just
said like when you when you do find a
dominant male you do bend to their will
do you think maybe it's because
like your energy is not picking up on
them being like a dominant male so
that's why you're going against then i
would argue he's not actually a dominant
and based on what pearl just said
if you don't have that ease of being
like you know what i trust you you will
submit to him and she's right he has to
be a man worthy of submitting to not
just any man and i would actually take
it even further and to say that it's
actually the onus is on men here to
prove that he is a masculine dominant
man for you to submit because i will
absolutely give you every right to say
i'm not going to submit to you if he's
not proven any of those things i'll
absolutely give you that right just to
add to the point
if a man says to you you know change
your outfit
can you okay so the reason i would say
okay cool is because i i'm seeing it as
the man is seeing something that men
would see that we wouldn't even pick up
on and if your partner is somebody you
trust and value his opinion and his
position he's seeing something that
you know
look at the camera and say that
hi guys
but um
so your partner is seeing something that
basically
other men will see and you might not
necessarily pick on pick up on that as a
woman so as a man he's saying to you
look i can see what other men are going
to be looking at or going towards when
you're outside dressed like that and i
think
disrespectfully as a partner as a
partnership and it's no different than
your dad looking at you about to walk
out the house revealing and saying i
don't want you to be preyed on by boys
it's no different
but that's it
you just you just rolled in my last
comment right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so
um i think it's important when your
partner does express that to you you you
know look at it for on real terms why
would why would he say that to you if
i'm not saying that actually every time
you step out you have to kind of
re-evaluate your position in that
situation yeah would you say so what
would what do you think about people
that would say well
i should be able to walk around naked
and be safe well you should
i just thought let me through it
okay one there's laws so you can't do
that
but you know what i mean
and two i mean you you could do that
single like
i don't want a guy to walk around naked
no you wouldn't yeah
but um i'm actually gonna read super
chats and wrap up the show this has
actually been a really fun show
um so i'm gonna read the last couple of
super chats that we have so
cyron manser the amount of bs they are
spewing
oh wait wait hold on hold on i gotta
refresh because that one's uh oh that
was violent no no hold on hold on that
wasn't the last one i know it wasn't and
then we're gonna go around and everyone
does their final thoughts after i read
these um s t f u f f s this is a good
group sarah would make it perfect we
miss you sarah um ata a man who wants
who wants a boss
a woman is a will smith and
and the outcome on his life but teresa
o'neil describes what a woman does to a
man when she's the boss listen to teresa
o'neil sharks theory gus pro footballers
marry average women all the time 90 free
to pay pearl please ask the females if
they did not have
the cat how would they keep a man
90 free toe free tope but theresa
o'neill said that money fame only makes
you equal to a female you still need
game any girl at mcdonald's are invited
to a party just because of her but a guy
a man has to be
money have money or be famous just to be
equal to them black is panther
i disagree modern women don't know what
an ambitious man looks like even when
it's right in their faces they are drawn
to good looks hypnotized by vibes and
have their souls stolen by good pipe
game
cyromancer the amount of bs they are
spewing if that was true the guy making
35k would have way more options y'all
are capping brett cormier a hundred
percent bs pro i read this one already
this is the 250k vincent dolene jr how
does he fit all of that simping into one
orange hoodie
ata toxic men bad boy mimics alpha
masculine
said jbp
jc
i'm spending two
um
i'm spending two dollars just to call
eddie a simp
um
90 free topang patrice o'meal once said
that modern western women make men feel
like clark kent but once the men travel
abroad they discover they are superman
ata jordan peterson last night said
something along the lines that toxic bad
boys bad boy mimics are an alpha
responsible man diego asked the orange
guy if he felt uncomfortable while she
talked about emasculated men eddie e
black lady in green i didn't see you
there you look lovely to the lady with a
pretty face in the ugly pants i'd hit a
put i'd put a ring on it hit me up um 90
free toe pain how are you doing karl
gotten ugly bf do you want one
tmac 1979 don't ever bring an
argumentative chick left back very
painful to watch kirby if his kid can go
to an ivy league ivy should he make them
all go to community college so he can
pay for all of them what happens when
the when it's bigger than mcdonald's
journey to premise
prosperity ask the guy in orange if he
was raised by both parents 90 free tope
any male who laughs after making a point
is not in control of their emotions yes
i'm talking about the orange hoodie
kirby um no comment alistar horton pearl
ask all present did they oh that that
was the emotions one i think i'm gonna
refresh it one more second
just to make sure there's no other ones
also guys sign up for our memberships to
be a part of the chat the second half of
the video like the video because
honestly guys a like is free you don't
have to super chat if you watch but
liking the video let's get to a thousand
five hundred likes before the stream
ends there's over
i don't know how many people are in here
but um okay and the uk economist if you
want your kids to attend private school
and to have more opportunities to get a
head start in life the lower earning man
cannot provide this um anis can for the
super logical facts over feelings
brother use your logic and come to the
realization that most humans are hella
emotional it's human nature okay so why
don't we do
final thoughts and then tell the people
where they can find you any social media
you want to plug so when you start
[Laughter]
i sum up with the last two and a half
hours no i so um so you can find me on
instagram at jordanfullerofficial
final thoughts
[Music]
just re-watch the damn tape
oh is it me go time yeah oh no don't
know done
so it's done at dailies instagram um i'm
one half of the domino effect podcasts
we cause havoc on there have similar
conversations like this with a great
great panelist pearl episode coming out
of us in two weeks that's domino effect
pod on tik tok and instagram
and yeah if you like sarah garvey
there's an episode of him laying into
some women as well so you want to see
some havoc then go over and see that
yeah guys they have actually a very
entertaining podcast so you you really
should go subscribe i i don't always
plug people's podcasts because some of
them are trash but theirs is actually
really good
if you don't follow us we got beef
the insta is astro elbow go and have a
look at my business as well canvas of
live
um i learned a lot today
um
i don't know i don't know what my my
overall voice
um you can find me on instagram um and
youtube as well do music reviews
dropping music reviews each and every
friday um and it's restyle underscore x
that's
r-i-s-t-y-l-e underscore x wait you do
music reviews what type of music you
review music that drops every friday so
it's mostly being like rap oh my god i
started this channel with rap reactions
we gotta do one we gotta do it i'm down
let's do it later
go ahead um yeah i'm not gonna plug the
instagram i'm quite private but i will
say this um conversation has been
enlightening to say the least i got a
bit fired up this week finally yeah i'm
getting used to it um and also just to
say to people always have a reflective
approach when you're having discussions
and be open to new views
yeah
um
dan i've enjoyed today actually because
some thoughts have been challenging in
terms of just like having extreme views
from
certain people in the room
but um overall yeah it's been a good
experience um
find me
find me um on instagram dan kamalafi so
that's k-o-m-o-l-a-f-e
for all things crossfit so if you're a
fitness person
find me there are you doing crossfit i
do that's a dope man yeah
okay guys um thank you so much for
liking the video we're at 1.4 000 likes
on the video guys let's get to 1.5 and
we almost had 3 000 viewers in here
yeah what's the record
uh three thousand we didn't we didn't
hit we didn't break the record today
don't let's not
okay um leave a comment about your
thoughts for the video agree disagree
leave a comment also ish is telling me i
need to start plugging my instagram
yeah so the link is in the description
to my instagram but it's just dot pearly
things i've always do announcements for
the show and some behind the scenes look
sign up for our memberships to be a part
of the chat the second half of the
stream am i forgetting to plug
anything-ish no not this time no not
this time okay okay okay guys um thank
you so much for watching um let me know
in the comments what topic we should do
next and we will talk to you next time
bye
[Music]